Ich glaube, das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Oder euro umgangssprachlich früher als hausfrauenmischung bezeichnet hat oder waren sie wieder am start auf twitter und haben sich aufgeregt
Wie kann man so ein sexistisches wort heutzutage auf twitter posten?
Triggert
Da ging es wieder rund hier ich ich will manchmal echt nicht mehr auf dem planet sein wenn ich twitter lese
Unerhört ja dabei war das offensichtlich so als fun fact zu erkennen ja
Weiß ich was da dran jetzt so schlimm war
Ja genau der tweet
Was kann sich echt über alles aufregen alder
Meine fresse hat man sonst echt gar nichts mehr zu tun
Soll ich mich soll ich mich jedes mal drüber aufregen wenn einer einen witz macht wenn einer zu dick ist oder irgendwas
Da hätte ich echt viel zu tun
Ich könnte mich über irgendwelche geek nerd informatiker witz beschweren
Ich kann mich über fat shaming beschweren
Aber ich denke mir einfach leck mich ist mir wurscht. Ich weiß dass es nur ein fun fact ist aber die leute haben es trotzdem über übertrieben aufgeregt mit auf twitter
komplett unverständlich
Ja das
Der entschuldigungs reflex ist ja mittlerweile schon normal bei allem auch wenn eigentlich
gar nichts war und man mal wirklich ernsthaft die leute sich darüber aufregen fragen müsste so nach dem motto habt ihr echt nichts besseres zu tun dann kommt dann wird erst mal riesen entschuldigung gefahren
Also ich habe kein problem einzugestehen wenn ich mist erzähle das würde ich auch immer so sagen im nachhinein so nach dem motto ich habe mist erzählen stimmt nicht
oder
Ich habe kein problem einzugestehen wenn ich miss erzähle das würde ich auch immer so sagen im nachhinein so nach dem motto ich habe mist erzählen stimmt nicht
oder sonst wie wenn ich wirklich persönlich davon überzeugt bin dass ich irgendwie mal absolut kack erzählt hab ja
Aber nicht für random sache nur weil sich leute empören
Ah ja gut
Meinetwegen sollen sie machen zu wollen
Max soll ich lieber bei telekom ausbildungen oder bei interaction also interaction sind die mit dem dezix
Telekom also ich kann ich kann es ja natürlich aus eigener hand nicht sagen ich habe gehört die telekom ausbildung ist gar nicht so schlecht
Interaction keine ahnung es ist technisch beides bestimmt cool und ich könnte mir vorstellen interaction ist
Eine nummer eine nummer mehr netzwerk und business backbauen provider mäßig orientiert eben als die telekom
Aber
Ja
Also ich persönlich würde zu interaction
Meiner meinung nach so rein bauchgefühl mäßig ich kann das jetzt nirgendswo festmachen
Ganz ehrlich
Man muss man muss also ich bin ja ich bin ja wirklich dafür für leben und leben lassen und man muss es nicht übertreiben
Ja und wenn ich weiß dass jemand anderes also ich persönlich jetzt wenn ich weiß dass es jemand anderes echt nervt
Dann versuche ich mir mühe zu geben es nicht zu sehr zu übertreiben aber man kann sich nicht darauf verlassen dass die ganze welt sich auf
Besonderheiten von einem einstellt das funktioniert einfach nicht und damit muss man früher oder später klarkommen
Dass ein nicht jeder komplett mit samt handschuhen anfasst
Wie wild du bist jetzt sonst keine 30 plus kriegst ja du kriegst ja komplexe mit das also das muss du auch du musstes aus reinem selbschutz
Schon irgendwann mal ein bisschen damit klarkommen wenn nicht andere Leute mit dem selbschutz
Schon irgendwann mal ein bisschen damit klarkommen wenn nicht andere Leute nicht nur mit samt handschuhen anfassen
Anders da geht es doch gar nicht
Ich sage nicht dass man leute ärgern soll ich wie gesagt mir tut es heute noch leid
Was mit dem einer zu wie der dann halben nervenzusammenbruch hatte
Genau ich finde auch es sollten durchaus wenn man es weiß alle ein bisschen rücksicht nehmen das bin ich bin ich sofort dabei
Aber man kann sich trotzdem nicht immer darauf verlassen dass die ganze welt sich nach den eigenen gefühlen richtet das passiert halt einfach nicht
Ja und natürlich nervt das sicherlich leute ich sage gut also
So wie ich hier im stream immer rum laber muss man denken ich habe den bmi 45 plus und
bin irgendwie
171 und wie 180 kilo nein so ist es ja nicht ich bin auch nicht mal dick genug
heißt auch nicht mal dick genug noch nicht mal dick genug dass ich bei den corona impfung früher dran kommen
Es ist auch nicht kurz vom platzen ja es ist halt einfach ein bisschen viel
Ja und ich verstehe dass dass ich da leute darüber aufregen und dass es sich zu herzen nehmen ich habe ich habe früher auch
mir sehr viel sehr viel sachen
Zu herzen genommen wenn sich einer drüber beschwert hat wenn ich irgendwie mist gebaut habe wobei ich so die die äußerlichen sachen mir nie
Sonderlich zu herzen genommen habe aber
Wenn einer wenn einer gesagt hätte ich hätte irgendwie was falsch gemacht was aber meiner ansicht nach richtig war da habe ich mich richtig drüber aufgeregt
Naja gut das also ich finde nicht dass man es drauf anlegen muss ja die leute soll ein bisschen rücksicht auf nahe nehmen das ist ok
Aber und das ist und das ist mein punkt also wenn ich jetzt weiß dass einer irgendwelche probleme hat dann wäre ich eben nicht direkt unter die nase reiben
Ja also insofern nehme ich wenn ich die leute kenne schon rücksicht drauf aber vieles weiß ich doch gar nicht
Ja und deswegen sage ich allein schon aus ein bisschen selbst schutz muss man sich nicht auf die nase reiben
Deswegen sage ich allein schon aus ein bisschen selbst schutz muss man darauf klarkommen dass einen eben nicht die gesamte welt mit mit samt handschuhen
Anfasst gar nicht mal unbedingt rein aus böse absicht die gibt sicherlich auch und es gibt genug leute die
Die
Legens drauf an andere leute fertig zu machen ja aber es kommt auch oft genug vor
Dass man manche sachen schlicht und ergreifend nicht weiß dass man in den doofen spruch machen
Man gar nicht weiß dass die leute davon betroffen sind dass sie das aufregt
und
Wie gesagt allein schon aus selbst schutz muss man ein bisschen klarkommen mit der zeit so schauen wir mal eine vm an
Was hat das mit n simple zu tun nix?
Poggers vm wird gestartet
Was soll das denn mit n simple zu tun haben das war so das war so eine typische trigger frage wo wir grad wo wir grad dabei sind
War sachen die an aufregend das ist so eine typische trigger frage du weißt genau dass das nix mit n simple zu tun hat
Du willst nicht schreiben was soll das scheiß stream das hat ja nix mit n simple zu tun du stellst jetzt quasi diese frage absichtlich so
So nach dem wortel was soll das scheiß hast ja auch recht
Aber ich habe doch gar nicht angefangen
So mal erst mal update mal gucken ob es irgendwas neues gibt genau also was ich vor habe ich erzähle euch das mal kurz
Rumpel twitch prime dankeschön für den snap ich erzähle euch mal kurz was ich vor habe und zwar ich bin ja grad dabei
Alle meine kisten die ich so betreibe und vor allem wo ich nicht oft was drauf mache und nach ein paar wochen wieder vergessen hat
Wie die ausschauen
Die sind ein bisschen zu veran an sibilieren
Aber wir schon mal ein bisschen das ist ja ich vergesse ich vergesse immer was das red hat mittlerweile
so und
Ich bin da grad dabei wie gesagt meine ganzen selber die es so hat ein bisschen bisschen in n simple konfig reinzupacken
Und eine sache ist mir aufgefallen die muss ich noch machen und habe ich mir gedacht ich können wir jetzt im stream machen und zwar
Ihr wisst ja dass ich übrigens wenn ihr was wissen wollt schreibt entwobblos in chat dabei ich gehe mal kurz in die andere vm
und starte mein
Chat log tool dass ich nix vergesse
und
Da mal kurz ausmachen wieder anmachen
Alter was ok das war jetzt aus dem letzten stream aber die kombination ist ja mal mega old school web min und
bind als dns
und
benutzt du für mqt aus und sich b2 m2 ja ja ja mache ich allerdings das dick hat mit sich b2 mqtt nix zu tun
das dick das ist ein ganz normaler sich b stick und
Um das in home assistant zu integrieren gibt es verschiedene varianten du kannst entweder mal getrückt teilen du kannst entweder die offizielle sich
b integration benutzen
Du kannst
sich b2 mqtt verwenden oder du kannst den dekons heißt glaube ich verwenden gibt es auch als offizielles erner und ich persönlich
bin mit mqtt am glücklichsten kann könnt ihr mal please schreiben entwobblos in chat mal gucken ob mein tool tut
stb a 42 danke für den sub
exzellent exzellent
Leute es funktioniert nicht
nicht warum nicht
Okay, ich muss noch mal ausmachen
das ist kaputt
Warum ist mein pepega bord kaputt wait a minute
das pepega bord ich wollte gerade sagen lul wie
Ja
Kein moment meint jetzt hier ad wo blots lul wie ha jetzt funktioniert sehr gut
Exzellent exzellent ok da kann ich nämlich die fragen gleich nachher aufgreifen die ich über sehe
Ab wann gibt es deinen gamers only
Schau wieder was willst du als mit gamers only alter jetzt wirst du jetzt willst mir gleich wieder erzählen
Erläutrigs hat gesagt ich würde mit ihm gamers only streamen oder irgendwie sowas das warst du da oder
Ich weiß gar nicht wie kommst du auf so kram
Nee habe ich nicht gesehen habe ich nicht gesehen
Aber das ist nice und wisst ihr was ich viel nicer finden würde wenn
Wenn die endlich mal ihre windows gui geschichte gefixt kriegen dass man mit dotnet auch wieder ordentlich windows guis programmieren kann
So wir sehen übrigens
immer noch vom letzten mal auf
Warum habe ich das jetzt alles doppelt auf?
monkaS
Wait a minute
IP ad welche IP hat das ding 39 ok ok da mache ich das aus der anderen vm auf und dann können wir anfangen
An die 5000 war es ne ach mensch oh nee nee nee ah
Jetzt da ist es
Ja ja gibt's gibt's ja hast recht gibt's ja theoretisch jetzt schon
mit mit elektron als einfacher ist für die paar server die ich habe und
Und weil ich das damals roland updaten wollte
Geht das überhaupt noch
Ich glaube ich habe nämlich das tauchen gelöscht
Ich steppe ich habe das tauchen gelöscht geht nicht mehr
Es ist haki
Oder mal gucken ob es noch funktioniert
Gucken ob es noch funktioniert name keck wait
Der kleine ist es der 11er
Ubuntu 20 kommen wir mal das neueste bemm und ob es noch funktioniert
Hatten die kein 2004 image
Und wie ist der kram noch mal
Alter jetzt ist ja gut lasst mich doch einfach jetzt was machen please cx 11
Was cx 11
Ja okay der api scheint noch zu funktionieren alles gut exzellent exzellent
Also den brauche ich jetzt ehe zack beim wobei nee den brauche ich habe doch schon längst ein server erstellt
Brauch doch gar nicht elefant oder auch für den zapp und bekleidung wieder löschen gleich wieder löschen
Ich habe das schon ein vorfeld ein server erstellt die lied
all die
so bäm wieder weg
zack 2 head
ja also
genau also ich
wollte erzählen was wir machen und zwar
ich bin da grad dabei wie gesagt
meine ganzen Server ein bisschen zu verautomatisieren
dass ich die Dinger wieder aufbauen kann wenn es abkackt
und eine Sache die ich noch machen muss
das ist aktuell auf meinem 1 Euro 1
und 1 Ionos Server drauf
weil ich hab für den irgendwas gebraucht was er
macht ja ich hab mir das Dinger
gekauft weil ich testen wollte ob die Dinger irgendwas
taugen und ich muss sagen für 1 Euro
im Monat ist es echt nicht schlecht
so also
und was ich mache ist folgendes ich
verwende hier daheim Home Assistant
kann euch leider das Dashboard immer noch nicht zeigen
weil zu sehr
zu sehr leak alles ja
aber das ist hier
das Ding was ich verwende
Demo Moment
Home Assistant Demo
so ungefähr sieht es bei mir auch aus wie in der Demo
ja so plus den Plan hab ich hier nicht
so sieht das bei mir auch ungefähr aus
ich hab hier oben ja noch Tabs
so und ich mach das so
dass ich erkennen kann wo die Leute sind
nämlich hier das da mit der Map
ähm
gibt's verschiedene Möglichkeiten für Presence Detection
man kann das über Google machen
man kann das über iCloud machen oder über
Live 360 oder sonst was
oder man kann das über
über
OwnTracks machen
das ist eine iOS App
die schickt das ganze über MQTT
was ich jetzt gemacht hab ist
ich hab auf meinem 1&1 Server
ein MQTT Broker drauf
und von dort ruft sich das
mein Home Assistant ab
warum ist das auf einem 1&1 Server
weil das muss im Internet sein weil
ansonsten kommt ja mein Handy nicht dran
die andere Variante die ich ursprünglich
mal ausprobiert hab
ist dass man
VPN aufbauen kann
dass ja OwnTracks sackt
aber das ist das einzige was es gibt
in der Richtung ich kenn nix anderes wenn du was anderes kennst
zeig ich ja ich find auch dass OwnTracks
sackt geht mir auch auf'n
das sackt und das geht mir auf'n Sack
so
und
du musst das halt übers Internet machen ich hab's am Anfang
probiert mit VPN
das Problem mit VPN ist
also VPN aufbauen und dann kann dann das Handy
direkt an meinen Home Assistant daheim die
Location schicken
das Problem ist nur
dass das IOS
typisch komplizierter ist als man
als man denkt denn
das VPN
wird im Hintergrund bei IOS abgebaut
und das VPN
ist nicht immer da wenn das
Location Tracking
sein Update schicken will also
90% der Requests gehen
in die Hose
und im Prinzip kann es sein dass die komplette Bahnfahrt
nicht drauf ist und jetzt brauche ich ja
zum Beispiel wenn ich auf dem Heimweg bin im Sommer
dass ich meine Klimaanlage einschalten kann wenn ich quasi
kurz vorm Arriven bin
das ist denglischsatz
so und deswegen wollte ich den Server jetzt mal automatisch
aufbauen und ich hab's bis heute
auch noch nicht richtig gescheit gemacht
aktuell ist es so das ist
ohne Zertifikate
also ohne Let's Encrypt
Zertifikate und alles
das ist einfach ein nackiger
MQTT Server
mit Alternifizierung davor
aber der Payload ist verschlüsselt das heißt das passt
eigentlich schon aber ich will es jetzt mal ordentlich machen
dann müssen wir erst mal gucken wie das Ganze funktioniert
so sieht's aus
René P8 Dankeschön für den Sub
es irritiert mich übrigens immer noch das Ganze jetzt
Prime Gaming heißt
wie hieß das nicht früher einfach
Twitch Prime und gut ist
warum
haben sie das unbenannt
war Jeff wieder
langweilig oder
so loggen wir uns mal kurz auf dem Server ein den ich
erstellt hab für das WIT
wo ist er
ach die haben ernsthaft ich seh es grad ich mach
das nehme ich grad zum Rebuilden
Hetzner hat
kein Ubuntu 20.10 Image
echt nett
hey wundere mich jetzt eigentlich
ne tatsächlich guck mal
stimmt außerdem ist Jeff nicht mal bei Amazon hast recht
warum haben die kein 20.10
wofür
kann man MQTT eigentlich alles verwenden
für alles
wo du so ein Message
Bus Ding brauchst
ein leichtgewichtiges ja
warum haben die
kein 20.10
Jeff
nein der der will irgendwelche
nulltätigen Projekte machen oder sowas hat er erzählt glaube ich
ich bilde mir auch ein dass die 20.10
hatten
guck mal
das ist aber gar nicht das ist einfach nicht aktuell
das aber
guck mal ich hab es hier versucht gerade zu erstellen
mit 20.10 ging auch nicht
guckt hier guckt hier mal
Cacquait ich hab 20.10
angegeben und es ging da nicht
aber ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher dass die das hatten
aber hier beim Rebuilden kann ich das nicht auswählen
haben die vielleicht
irgendwelche Probleme und haben das deswegen raus
genommen
ne oder ich bin einfach zu blöd und hab es nicht
gecheckt
das kann natürlich auch sein
wahrscheinlich das
schreib den Support
ne Quatsch mit 20.04 ist vollkommen ok
so
Bäm
also wie immer das erste
was wir machen ist
achso wo hab ich denn mein Enzymel Kram
ufw allow ssh
ufw default
deny ufw
enable so Firewall an jetzt kann
nichts mehr passieren
wir wissen ja
Firewall enabled prinzipiell gleich
das ist ungefähr so wie
wenn das Programm kompiliert dann gehts auch
dementsprechend kann mit Firewall
an auch nichts mehr passieren
wo hab ich denn mein ganzen Enzymel Kram
hin ah hier guck mal da
ich hab ernsthaft Leute was ist denn mit mir
los ich hab ernsthaft mal nen Ordner gemacht wo man
Sachen wiederfindet seh ich das richtig
ok
oh ne ich hab die Hälfte aber gelöscht
warum hab ich da so viel rausgeschmissen
wait a minute
wir hatten doch sogar
Kaddi Installationen und sowas da alles schon drin
ich hab kein Bock das nochmal neu zu machen
gut es war nicht so
kompliziert
ich verwende Mosquito weil das das einzige
ist was dabei ist
und was man easy konfigurieren
also easy in Anführungsstrichen konfigurieren kann
wo ist mein Enzymel
konfig hin
exellent
hab ich das hier gelöscht
ha
exellent
JIT FTW
Alter
nice da ist nämlich der ganze Kram noch drin
das brauch ich gleich wieder ich war ok
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher warum ich den Kram
warum ich den Kram rausgeschmissen hab
aber
ok
äh
ey
ey warte mal
ich will jetzt keinen Mist machen
konnte man
nicht einfach reset minus heart sagen
und dann geht es auf
den letzten commit
ich bin mir da jetzt aber nicht so sicher
ich
also in dem Fall ob ich commit hab
so jetzt ist die Frage ist es da oder nicht
bäm da ist bitte alles
alles klar so
also
wunderbar ganze Krempel ist da
Ansiebele
ja dann lassen wir das doch gleich mal laufen
haben wir visual studio code
auf
lassen wir die basic install lassen wir doch schon mit ansiebele
machen alles was wir schon haben
ne nicht test äh das Ding hab ich gar nicht
test sav
custom domain
remote user root
ok also was machen wir
wir machen update install
telnet git
allow ufw allow http
machen wir das
gleich
das lassen wir erstmal weg
ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher
ob ich das haben will
so da wird caddy installiert
caddy repo
reverse proxy
das mach ich auch mal raus
da bin ich mir nicht so sicher ob wir das brauchen
ok dotnet
das ganze dotnet zeug
das kann weg
das brauch ich nicht
das ganze dotnet zeug war für den preis champ
das brauchen wir nicht
aber ich kann schon mal mein ansiebele kram laufen lassen
gucken wir mal ob der jetzt den server ordentlich
einrichtet
äh warte mal
wie ging das
hosts
das brauchen wir alles nicht
das können wir im prinzip weg machen wir brauchen einfach nur
test sav
habe ich das teil genannt
ansiebele
mal ausführen
wie war das jetzt
einfach hosts
inventory
hosts
und dann base yaml ausführen
ok also von der
ide her sollte der sich jetzt auf dem server
einloggen alles konfigurieren
so dass ich dann
den kram weitermachen kann
und gucken wie es funktioniert
der sollte mir das ding updaten
der sollte mir basic basic tools
drauf installieren
musik ist ein ticken laut oder
stückchen
stückchen leiser manchmal
so
da sollte mir also als update basic tools installieren
ssh erlauben ufw
einschalten und kadi als
reverse box installieren also ich habe mir das
gedacht wir machen folgendes auf den server drauf
wie gesagt mein ziel ist am ende
dass wir einen mqtt server
haben plus lets
encrypt
ah ich habe meinen num block nicht an
plus lets encrypt
so dann brauchen wir
einen prometoys note
exporter drauf weil ich mir
gerne crafts angucke
und
dann habe ich auch gleich einen endpunkt um
die gültigkeit vom zertifikat
zu testen
so weit die ide
also das heißt wir brauchen dann einen
reverse proxy proxy
das mal mit kadi das ist dann am einfachsten
das sind zwei zeilen konfig
läuft der broker bei der durchgänge musst du ihn regelmäßig
neu den läuft durch der läuft durchgängig
den muss ich nur neu den muss ich nur
neu starten
wenn sich das
zertifikat update da muss ich auch mal gucken wie man das
macht so
wir brauchen also eine reverse proxy wir brauchen
einen mqtt server da nehmen wir
mosk das kann ich mir nicht schreiben
mosk
to
mittlerweile weiß ich mir halbwegs wie man schreibt
ja und die
zertifikate bin ich mir nicht sicher
ob wir die zerts mit kadi
oder mit
zertbot machen der vorteil an
zertbot ist der kann beispielsweise
nachdem man ein zertifikat
aktualisiert hat dienste neu starten
müssen wir mal gucken ob das
ob das sinn ergibt
ja
mir wäre es eigentlich lieber ich bräuchte kein
zertbot sondern einfach nur die zwei sachen
snap
nee
kein snap
snap
so hat das jetzt geschafft
changed 5
nice
exellent so also
jetzt sollte der server frisch aufgebaut sein
es sollte beispielsweise ein hardtop drauf sein
sollte ein git drauf sein
und es sollte auch so was wie
endload drauf sein
sehr gut nice
also basic
basic
ansible konfig hat funktioniert
ups ich habe mich vertippt
ich wollte das auf desktop 3 schieben
so ist kadi installiert
jawoll sehr gut
status
nice nice nice okay
das hat funktioniert also die basic
die basic sachen gehen schon mal
das ist nice da muss ich das
da muss ich das schon mal nicht machen so und jetzt muss ich mir überlegen wie kriege ich es gebacken
dass ich den ganzen
kram hier drauf krieg so dass es dann möglichst
easy in ansible umzusetzen
ist und dass es gültiges zertifikat
krieg
danke für den snap ex
exquisite subscription kann man
kadi mit traffic vergleichen
Leute ihr müsst unbedingt wenn ihr was wissen wollt add wubblos davor machen weil
ansonsten überseh ich den kram
ich hab nämlich hier extra so ein
so ein ding mit laufen
was alles an mich mitlockt
dass ich nicht übersehe
ja du kannst kadi ein bisschen
traffic vergleichen
nur mit dem unterschied dass die kadi
konfig viel viel einfacher ist
traffic kann potenziell
build in mehr
aber die konfig ist eklig
ich warte ja noch drauf
dass irgendwann mal einer was baut wo die
konfig easy ist alle möglichen
sachen integriert hat
und was
mit allem sich auch gut integrieren lässt
das ist
das also
tom shinnelli das ist
nur bei mir so das hab ich mir gebastelt
also das bei anderen nicht so aber
du siehst hier wenn du add den name von
jemand schreibst da kriegt er das
halt so gehighlighted das ist ganz praktisch
und je nachdem und wenn du neu
bist wenn du neu bist eine sache
was man prinzipiell ja allen
empfehlen muss die neu auf twitch sind
siehst du
siehst du dieses emote hier
bei dir
oder steht hier pause champ
du siehst das ok
dann hast du schon passendes addon installiert
gut weil das ist das allerwichtigste
ffz installieren mit better twitch tv
extension
dann ohne ist twitch nicht
nicht benutzbar
so geupdatet hat er auch jetzt muss ich ja gar keine
basics mehr machen
da steht pause champ ja dann
brauchst du unbedingt das hier
falls du chrome hast
firefox geht auch
du brauchst unbedingt den da
und dieses addon pack
äh moment
ich bin verwirrt falsch rum
brauchst dieses addon und dann das
better twitch tv addon pack oder better twitch tv direkt
es ist so ein bisschen
es ist so ein bisschen glaubensfrage ob man
ffz verwendet
oder better twitch tv unterm strich machen
der addon ist das gleiche
gibt mehr emote
und der chat ist einfacher zu lesen
das ist
das ist beste
ich lasse mich vom chat permanent ablenken das ist normal
für presence detection
mit meinem iphone will ich die einsetzen
bzw. setze ich die schon ein
aber ich will sie jetzt mal veransibilisieren
dass ich es benutzen kann
ok also ab install
install
mosquito brauma
mosquito clients brauma zum ausprobieren
so das muss ich mir aufschreiben
das muss ich gleich
das muss ich gleich rein machen
in installer
genau das muss ich gleich in installer rein machen
weil sonst vergesse ich das garantiert
alles latest
ja ja latest passt
erstmal direkt anmachen
aber denk dran
bevor du ufw anmachst
mach den hier
ufw allow ssh ansonsten sperrst du dich selbst aus
das warnt dich
auch nochmal vorher
wie würdest du die anwesenheit
mit android umsetzen
mit android würde ich wahrscheinlich
ähm
einfach nen tasker task
machen der meine gps dinger
in irgendeinem format wo ich sie verarbeiten kann wohin schickt
da gibt es glaube ich bessere varianten
unter android als own tracks
own tracks sackt ein bisschen
hab ich das jetzt eigentlich installiert
oder hab ich vorher abgebrochen
also installiere
mosquito mosquito clients
so
dann nachdem man installiert hat
systemctl enable
hallo
ok
meinetwegen
so wie mach ich das in ansible
state enabled
moment
state state state
konnte man das nicht direkt
ansible
enable service
kann man das gleich
im installer machen
ok das das das
funktioniert kann man das nicht
mit dem installer machen
dass man gleich sagen kann wie enabled
oder sowas
ne anscheinend nicht ok das heißt
brauchen wir nochmal hinten drauf
zack
jaja
enable
ne warte mal enable
nein nein stimmt ja gar nicht was ich mach
was kopiere ich mir denn hier für einen crap
enable
enabled
hier das da brauche ich
cacquade
so das da enabled yes
wunderbar
gut
so
die firewall
machen wir da vor
dass das eingeschaltet wird
bevor ich irgendwelche services installiere
ist glaube ich sinnvoller
theoretisch können wir die firewall sogar ganz
am anfang machen warum einschnitt
wir machen die firewall einfach ganz am anfang
ok also jetzt muss ich erstmal selbst gucken
wie das wie das ganze funktioniert also
ich hab den kram installiert enabled
und jetzt ist die große preisfrage wie mach ich
das mit den zertifikaten
etc wir machen uns
mal wir machen uns mal wir lassen uns
mal ein zertifikat ausstellen
über caddy und dann gucken wir ob wir das
irgendwie da rein bekommen weil ich hab ehrlich
gesagt kein bock auf zertbot
ich hab vorher ein ganz gutes how to gefunden
bei digital ocean
aber das mit zertbot hat mir nicht gefallen
wie die das vorgeschlagen haben
die machen das nämlich so
das ist auch ne sache die hab ich auch am anfang gedacht
und zwar
installieren den ganzen kram
blablabla und dann machen sie nen hook
machen sie nen hook
bei beim zertbot
und immer wenn das
zertifikat neu erstellt wurde
starten sie den service neu
aber das brauch ich wahrscheinlich nicht
moment der zertbot kommt bei ubuntu über snap
nett wirklich oder
was
wirklich
das doch warum
das steht
natürlich nicht dabei
oh
ich hab mich verklickt
ich wollt den anderen timeout
null
ups
war ich unbandig
wieder
marcel sh
null
jetzt wird der richtige timeout
keck wait
aimed
na aimed
nee das war einfach input
lag im chat
der karlson 17 monate am start
massive alter
17 monate du bist ja schon ewig am start
wo ist denn hier hyper subscription
hier
ein geschnitt für den sub
ich seh dich nicht oft im chat aber trotzdem
leider dass du so lange schon am start bist
zertbot instructions
warum ich will das nicht über snap
snap ist übelster crap
was ist mit den ubuntu leuten los
alter mit jubanto
leuten
ja über app installiert er aber auch einen snap
ist ja auch egal ich hoffe wir brauchen das gar nicht
ok
side tracked
wo bin ich denn stehen geblieben genau etc
kadi
kadi file kadi ist wirklich
easy as fuck also wenn ihr eine universe proxy braucht
wirklich ihr könnt eigentlich da nichts
falsch machen mit kadi
die config ist auch total einfach
man nimmt einfach die domain wo das ganze
erreichbar sein soll
ich bau nen mqtt server
der nen gültiges zertifikat hat was ich für
location tracking für mein iphone
verwenden kann allerdings nicht den server
ich werd hier keine koordinaten gps koordinaten
leaken gleich
deutlich einfacher als engine x
und bei engine x geht auch also im vergleich zu apache
ist alles einfach
aber kadi ist wirklich easy
also für nen zertifikat
guck mal also alles was du machen musst
für nen zertifikat engine x
kann ja glaube ich standardmäßig gar kein letzten crypt
du musst es entweder über nen zertbot machen oder
ein anderes script oder über docker
wo dann wiederum ein zertbot mit verpackt ist
so du sagst einfach test
server so das ist die domain
die hab ich schon umgebogen im dns
port 443 das kannst du dir
by the way alles sparen
hier rein zu schreiben da geht da automatisch
von aus aber
ich finds besser wenn man das angibt
so ok
ich zähm ccl restart kadi
jetzt guck mal ob das
mit den zertifikaten
funktioniert hat
ok er macht zertifikat
zeug probieren wir das mal aus
test srv
geht nicht
achso
warum gehts wohl nicht leute
wer hat aufgepasst warum gehts
nicht ist eigentlich relativ
klar
firewall korrekt
allow https
bam
och
test srv
achso
https
ok
ich hab kadi schon neu gestartet
noch mal
neu starten muss ich den doch nicht
mach ich
no
ok
Ach stimmt, ich mach ja hier gar kein DNS-Challenge.
Ah, ja das geht nicht. Ich muss Port 80 erlauben.
Ich muss Port 80 erlauben, sonst geht's nicht.
Weil, ich mach normalerweise den ganzen Kram über DNS-Challenge.
Da brauchst du keinen Port frei.
Aber hier ist es ja ganz normal HTTP-Challenge, wo Let's Encrypt nachguckt, ob ne Textdatei rumliegt.
So, und das geht natürlich nur, wenn Port 80 frei ist.
Schreibt ihr irgendeinen Log?
Naja, Log gibt's nicht, ja.
So, schauen wir mal, ob's jetzt funktioniert.
Ah, yes. Jetzt funktioniert's Leute.
Ja, wir werden nicht Rate-Limited. Also, wenn ihr auf die Uhlen geht, solltet ihr das eigentlich auch sehen.
By the way, die Seite ist absichtlich so shabby.
Irgendjemand bei Kaddi hat sich gedacht, das ist ne gute Idee.
Ich bin so offen.
Okay, wir müssen übrigens bei der Uhr irgendwo gerade dabei sein.
UFW SSH erlauben, HTTP erlauben und HTTPS erlauben.
Kann man, UFW Ansible, kann man mehrere Firewallen-Regeln auf einmal machen?
Alternativ könnt ihr einfach euren Kopf ein bisschen schräg machen, dann ist es wieder gerade.
Ah, man kann Port Ranges machen, das will ich nicht.
Ich will ja nur zwei Sachen. Das geht anscheinend nicht.
Ich kann da doch bestimmt ne Liste angeben, oder?
Ich kann doch bestimmt machen, Port, HTTP und HTTPS, hä?
HTTP und HTTPS, hä?
Werden wir gleich sehen, ob das funktioniert, wenn ich es dann ausprobiere.
Jemanden Ahnung, ob das geht?
Es ist nicht, es ist nicht in den Beispielen drinne, also.
Warum nicht als Docker-Container? Ja, das ist die andere Alternative.
Aber nachdem das mit Docker und UFW und so nicht richtig funktioniert und ich den Kram nur einmal hinstellen muss,
ich hab's mir überlegt, ob ich nicht ein Docker-Compose-File mache.
Aber ganz im Ernst, so ist es auch nicht.
Ich kann ja nicht sagen, was davon jetzt besser, in dem Fall gefällt mir die Variante, also die Ansible Variante besser.
Aus dem Docker ist out, die coolen Leute verwenden Potman. Naja, zum Glück nicht.
Umso weniger Redhat, umso besser, ja. Schauen wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
Leute, by the way, ich hab gehört, angeblich, ich weiß den Account nicht und wenn ich den Account wüsste, würde ich ihn euch nicht sagen.
Mein Chef streamt angeblich jetzt auch auf Twitch, hat er letztens erzählt.
Ich weiß aber weder welche Games noch sonst was.
Ich will den Account auch gar nicht wissen. Ich will nicht, dass ich draus versehen mal irgendwie erzähle
oder da im Chat schreibe und der dann was erzählt und dann mal wieder Zeugssachen liegt und... Nee.
Rain, ich weiß den Account gar nicht.
Okay, also, das funktioniert jetzt. Exzellent.
So, hier, Leute, Pot, wunderbar, hier, huge certificate.
UfwPort80, ja, das müsste jetzt das Gleiche sein, im Endeffekt, was ich hier gemacht hab.
Also, was du geschrieben hast, ist die Array, die Yammel Array Schreibweise und das hier müsste die Jason Schreibweise sein, die müsste eigentlich auch gehen.
Vermutig mal, werden wir dann sehen. Aber jetzt muss ich den ganzen Kram erstmal zum Laufen bekommen.
Ähm, okay, also, ich hab ne Moskito installiert. Läuft der denn schon?
Yup. So, was denn das? TMP, DLT, cannot be opened. Ach, scheiß drauf, ich mein, ey, solange das ordentlich runnt, ist mir das egal.
Okay, also, lass mal, wie können wir mit Image gehen. Wir haben den Web-Server.
Wir haben eine gültige Zertifikation. Wir haben einen Web-Server.
Wir haben eine Moskito installiert, also ein MQTT-Server. Jetzt brauch ich noch ein Prometheus Note-Exporter für nice crafts.
Kann ich euch ja gleich zeigen, wie man das einrichtet.
Ähm, dann machen wir ein schönes Grafana-Dashboard.
Sieht dann immer schön aus.
Äh, ex... Nee, das heißt Prometheus Note-Exporter, oder? Ja.
In welcher hier reich... Was ist das schon ins... Ach, das ist da. Ach, Moment, hab ich das vielleicht in der Basic-Insertion?
Ah, Big Brain-Leute. In welcher Hierarchie ist dein Chef-Chef? Äh...
Das ist, glaub ich, die erste Management-Ebene.
CEO, genau. Fortstandsvorsitzender. Nein, das ist die erste... Ich glaub, das ist die erste Management-Ebene.
Also quasi so eine Art Team-Leiter.
Ich kann mir immer nicht merken, ob es Team-Leiter, Gruppen-Leiter oder irgendein Team-Leiter ist.
Ich kann mir immer nicht merken, ob es Team-Leiter, Gruppen-Leiter ist.
Also quasi so eine Art Team-Leiter. Ich kann mir immer nicht merken, ob es Team-Leiter, Gruppen-Leiter oder irgendwie anders nennen.
Das ändert sich bei uns alle halbe Jahr mal. Ich sag einfach immer mal Team-Leiter.
Wir haben bei uns auf der Arbeit sowieso eine lustige Geschichte. Die sind wirklich laufend dabei.
Die haben auch irgendwelche Beratungsleute und so am Start.
Die sind laufend dabei, irgendwelche Dinge um zu strukturieren und um zu definieren und um zu prozessen und sonst was.
Die beste Reaktion bei uns auf der Arbeit, wenn jemand ankommt und sagt,
Leute, es gibt jetzt ein ganz neues, wichtiges Verfahren. Prozess 578.000 und das ist so.
Und mit Liste und Checkliste und sonst was. Das erste, was man machen muss, ist nichts.
Einfach mal drei Monate warten und gucken, ob man jemals wieder was von hört.
Die Chancen stehen gut, dass man von 80% der Sachen nie wieder was hört.
Und das ist unglaublich, wie oft das hilft.
Genau, Keeper Exypselon.
Man muss einfach erstmal nichts machen. Einfach erstmal abwarten.
Und es gibt auch ganz viele Dinge bei uns, die dann erstmal komplett im Sand verlaufen.
Die sind jetzt ganz wichtig und müssen jetzt sofort gemacht werden und jeder muss sich dran halten.
Und irgendwie ein halbes Jahr später hört man dann, der Typ, der das damals angekündigt hat, ist nicht mehr in dieser Position.
Wir hatten auch letztens sowas, da sollten wir an jedes Ticket, an jedes Ticket, sollte irgendwie so ein spezielles,
wie nenne ich das jetzt am besten, ohne es zu genau zu genau zu sagen, so ein spezielles Ticket sollte verknüpft werden.
Jedes Mal sollte das verknüpft sein mit dem eigentlichen Ticket.
Und der Typ, der das angeleitet hat, ist jetzt nicht mehr auf dieser Position.
Das ist so geil, das geht bei uns immer nicht ganz so koordiniert zur Sache, ja.
Und dann widersprechen sie sich auch immer.
Auf der einen Seite kommen sie an, hey, wir wollen das jetzt super statisch und prozessorientiert und nach Dingsablauf genormt und sonst was.
Und auf der anderen Seite sagen sie, Leute, wir müssen agil sein.
Keeper XY, nein, die Tickets müssen immer noch verknüpft sein, aber das war halt witzig, das hat sich nicht erledigt.
Das hat sich nicht erledigt, das ist immer noch so, aber der Typ ist nicht mehr da, der es mit eingeführt hat.
Weiß nicht, da hat er keinen Bock mehr drauf irgendwie.
Die brauchen die Hilfe von Peter Agile, ja.
Und das widerspricht sich total.
Du kannst nicht auf der einen Seite alles komplett geregelt haben wollen und dann auf der anderen Seite agil sein.
Entscheidet euch für eins.
Das eine mit dem anderen zusammen, das funktioniert nicht.
Und was auch immer witzig ist, ich komme jetzt voll ins Lammern, aber was auch lustig ist, sie erzählen manchmal so, ey Leute, Stabilität ist das Allerwichtigste.
So, als nächstes kommt, übrigens, das geht hier alles nicht schnell genug, das muss alles schneller gehen.
Okay, das heißt, wir wollen jetzt Stabilität und Schnelligkeit.
Okay, ist ja noch machbar, ist ja noch machbar, aber dann kommt als drittes und das ganze Zeug ist zu teuer.
So, das heißt, man möchte günstig, das passt aber nicht zusammen.
Also, es gibt drei Sachen, die gehen nicht zusammen.
Stabil, schnell und günstig, das geht nicht.
Du kannst stabil und schnell machen, dann wird es garantiert nicht günstig.
Du kannst schnell und günstig machen, dann wird es garantiert nicht stabil.
Du kannst, keine Ahnung, stabil und günstig machen, dann wird es nicht schnell.
Das geht alles nicht in Kombination.
Wo ich meine Domains-Miete bei Pogban, aber die empfehle ich nicht, die waren einfach nur die billigsten.
Das ist bei uns so paradox irgendwie, das ist voll paradox bei uns.
Wir sagen das ein und machen das andere, aber da habe ich mich schon gewöhnt, das ist unser Style sozusagen.
Hast du schon eine Emoji-Domain? Nein, habe ich nicht.
So, also weiter, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben, Leute?
Node-Exporter ist am Start.
So, bei der Gelegenheit, dann machen wir doch mal den Node-Exporter public verfügbar.
So, jetzt kann ich euch mal zeigen, wie easy das mit Cuddy ist, den Node-Exporter public verfügbar zu machen.
Also, wir haben hier unsere Domain, test-sav-mau.house.
So, da läuft ja aktuell dieser Testserver drauf, den wollen wir nicht.
Wir wollen eigentlich nichts anderes, wie alles, was da reinkommt, reverse-proxy auf den Port vom Prometheus.
Ich glaube, das ist es. So, und nun wollen wir noch einen Basic-Auth davor machen, dass das nicht jeder aufrufen kann.
Was spielst du eigentlich aktuell für Spiele?
Tja, also ich habe in letzter Zeit wieder relativ viel Battlefield 3 gespielt, mal gucken, ob da jetzt Leute auf dem Server sind nebenbei.
Ich werde das nicht spielen, interessiert mich nur mal, ist wahrscheinlich wieder RIP, wenn es komplett dead.
Ich spiele ab und zu noch ein bisschen Path of Exile, ansonsten ich warte händeringend drauf, dass mal irgendwie ein geiles Suchtgame wieder kommt.
Aber...
Okay, Deadgame.
Dass wieder ein richtig geiles Suchtgame kommt, aber kommt ja nichts.
So, by the way, mehr muss man nicht machen für Kadi-reverse-proxy inklusive automatisch SSL.
Eigentlich richtig nice. So, aber wir machen noch Basic-Auth, Kadi, Hash, Passwort.
So, jetzt wollte ich mir ein Passwort ausdenken, was ihr nicht erraten könnt.
So.
Bam.
Gehashtes Passwort.
So, und jetzt weiß ich gar nicht, wie man das reinschreibt. Äh, so.
Basic-Auth.
Bob.
Nicht Bob. Basic-Auth.
Lulve.
Ist das jetzt das Richtige, was ich hier genommen hab? Oder wie war das das hier? Nee, das war das Richtige.
Bin drin. Nice Chat. Sehr gut.
Excellent, excellent. Ich hab nicht immer reloaded, aber der Chat ist schon drin, ne?
Hetzer Cloud. Äh, ich schwa... Ich wechsle immer zwischen Nürnberg und Faltenstein ab.
Ich hab aktuell Server in allen drei RZs. Dass ich immer schön andere IPs kriege.
So. Äh, Basic-Auth. Zack.
Ich glaub, man braucht... Ich glaub, man braucht das hier gar nicht. Dann gilt's für alles.
Bin ich aber gar nicht so sicher. Ich glaub, man braucht das gar nicht.
So, Kaddi Restart. So, und wenn ihr jetzt alles richtig gemacht habt, dann fragt mich Kaddi nach einem Passwort.
Bam.
Und ich guck jetzt mal, ob das funktioniert.
Äh, was hab ich... Was hatte ich noch mal für'n User?
Lulve. Ja, Lulve. So, Passwort wisst ihr nicht.
Save.
Äh, Matrix.
Äh.
Warte mal, was... Was ist denn die... Was ist denn der Prometheus-Default-Port? Hab ich mich... Hab ich mich vertippt?
Oh. Moment. Netz-Stats.
Ach, neun. Das ist ja gar nicht... Das ist ja der Nodex-Porter. 9-1-0-0.
Ah ja, fast. Aber eins muss ich noch machen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der Engine X... Äh, ich sag mal, der Engine X-Fan noch da ist. Äh, das ist einfacher, oder?
Das musste... Muss zugeben. Also, deswegen mag ich den Kram auch.
Auf jetzt. Bam. Da sind meine Prometheus-Metrix. Sehr schön. Die brauchen wir schon mal.
Excellent Prometheus-Metrix.
Ich hab dich erfolgreich von Caddy überzeugt. Excellent. Caddy hat ein paar Probleme. Also äh... Z.B. mit dem
Ich hab dich erfolgreich von Kadi überzeugt, exellent.
Kadi hat ein paar Probleme, also, ähm, zum Beispiel ist DNS-Authentifizierung für letzten
Clip nicht eingebaut, brauchst du irgendwelche komischen Plugins und, äh, ich weiß nicht,
ich hatte letztens auch ein paar Sachen, die ging mit Kadi nicht gescheit.
Also, wenn man einfach einen Basic-Web-Server braucht, also, ne, wenn man das braucht, was
es kann, ist gut, wenn es darüber hinausgeht, kommt man an entweder Traffic, wenn man irgendwas
Docker-Heavy hat oder ansonsten so der Klassiker, äh, Nginx, für alles auch trotzdem nicht
vorbei.
Musstest du den 9001-UFW freischalten?
Nein, den muss ich nicht freischalten, weil ich ja Reverse-Proxie, Reverse-Proxy von dieser
Domain auf Inter 9100, das ist ja grad der Sinn davon, ne, mit Basic-Auth davor, also
sprich, ihr könnt da jetzt nicht drauf zugreifen und es ist ziemlich easy.
So, wollen wir uns schnell mal ein Dashboard machen?
Komm, wir machen uns mal schnell Poggers Dashboard, einfach, einfach weil es funktioniert.
Aimcardier, Compose, wir machen uns Massive, Massive Dashboard für, äh, Sample, Grafana,
es geht schnell.
Compose, haben die da irgendeinen Basic, äh, genau, ne, das ist alles Müll, das stimmt
nicht, ja, das da ist schon mal gut, das brauchen wir, Latest, äh, Prometheus, blablabla, Volumes,
jawoll, Data, alles klar, brauchen wir Commands, wobei ich kann das doch einfach kopieren,
was ich schon fertig hab, lol, weh, warum, warum, warum bin ich denn, Moment, ich kopiere
einfach das, was ich schon hab.
Da war wir exzellent, exzellent, exzellent, äh, was bedeutet Reverse Proxy, ne, also,
was ein Proxy macht, weißt du wahrscheinlich, also, wenn du, ein Proxy fragt stellvertretend
für dich Internetseiten an, das heißt, du kannst über den Proxy ins Internet gehen,
ein Reverse Proxy ist das Umgedrehte, das Internet geht über den Proxy zu dir, ne,
über normalen Proxy, also quasi über ein Forward Proxy, ich weiß nicht, ob man das
so nennt, aber ich nenn's jetzt einfach mal so, gehst du auf den Proxy, der Proxy für
dich ins Internet, und dann wieder zurück und ergibt dir die Seite und ein Reverse Proxy
ist umgedreht, du gehst auf den, der Internet geht auf den Proxy und kommt damit zu dir,
äh, ich bin grad irgendwie, grad nicht in der Lage das richtig zu schreiben, äh, Expose,
Port, 90, 90, bla, Commands, brauchen wir alles nett, Prometheus, und jetzt brauchen
wir noch das Grafana Ding, exzellent, alles klar, und dann können wir das starten und
dann machen wir ein huge, massive, nicees Dashboard, das brauchen wir glaub ich auch
alles nicht, jaja, alles gut, perfekt, links, genau, das leitet alles was bei dem Port 443
reinkommt auf die, äh, auf das richtige weiter, so, ich hoffe ich hab jetzt das Docker Compose
richtig gemacht, ne, das ist schonmal falsch, was ich hier gemacht hab, guck mal, schonmal
verkehrt, so, und ich glaub man muss auch irgendwie oben ins Docker Compose was anderes
reinschreiben, oder, bin ich jetzt verwirrt, Docker Compose ab, ne, hä, musste man nicht
oben Versionen und sowas noch reinschreiben, normalerweise, warum geht denn das jetzt, warum,
ist das jetzt neu, dass das geht, can't quite, oh, wait a minute, was hab ich jetzt verkehrt
gemacht, wisst ihr was wir machen, wir machen einfach easy mode, wir machen easy mode, wir
machen easy mode, network, network, host, null, ich will einfach nur ein Dashboard haben,
ich will mich jetzt nicht zu lang damit beschäftigen, hab ich Sub's übersehen, eigentlich schon
für die Sub's, ich hab Creator Dashboard, ich hab nix gesehen, wen hab ich denn übersehen
wieder, ich hab doch gar keinen übersehen, Tom Schinelli, dankeschön, 24 Minuten hab
ich nicht gesehen, sorry, ja manchmal bin ich so am Hacker man machen, Massive Subscriptions,
ok also was, hier, network host, network host, ab, was, Moment, alter, wie war denn das jetzt,
networking host, use host, ah, network mode ist das, network mode, network mode, guck
mir jetzt Wimtrick, Wimtrick, Punkt drücken, bam, was, jetzt, verwirrt, ok, ok, ok, ok,
verwirrt, ne, ist nicht networking mode, networking, ok, wir machen, wir machen das Ding mal richtig,
irgendwas stimmt mit dem Pfeil nicht, gut, ich brauch so mini, mini example, genau, weiß
nicht was der für Schmerzen hat, alter, kann man das auf Gleicher, jawoll, ab, ah, sieht
schon besser aus, 08, max 07, 5 Monate, dankeschön für den Zapp, ok, Verzeichnung ist nicht
vorhanden, weil, keine Prometheus Config, ja gut, das weiß ich, aber ich darf jetzt
da nicht rein, ernsthaft, alter, bam, data, Prometheus, ich brauch irgendeine easy Prometheus
Config Wim, Punkt, und dann sollte es eigentlich funktionieren, genau, hier, exzellent, Prometheus
Yammel, so, dann haben wir mal, nice dashboard, massive poggers dashboard, passte, so, blablabla,
Scrape Interval 100, ok, Targets, TestSav.House, Port 443, ach so, wie mach ich, wie mach ich,
wie mach ich, Prometheus, ah ne, da muss ich jetzt mein Passwort im Klartext reinschreiben,
nein, wie mach ich das jetzt, MonkaS, ah, ok, ich guck erstmal, ob's läuft, ich guck
erstmal, ob's läuft, Leute, nein, das funktioniert jetzt natürlich nicht, ich will einfach nur
mal gucken, ob's jetzt startet, wenigstens, was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen, Config File,
it's not a valid host, ne, der ist wieder, der will's wieder wissen, doch nicht so einfach,
ich glaube, man muss, genau, ah, so geht das mit Basic Host, ok, interessant, genau das
brauchen wir, da geb ich jetzt allerdings noch nicht das Passwort ein, weil ansonsten
leak ich das Passwort, aber ich schreib schon mal alles rein, was man braucht, lps-basic-host-lw,
das ist nicht das richtige Passwort, so, darf ich jetzt, darf ich jetzt starten, ab, ab,
ah, ah, Gott, wo ist das Problem, was, Permission, please, das ist doch eigentlich gar nicht
so kompliziert, ok, ich kopier mir das jetzt einfach von meiner anderen Installation rüber,
da hab ich nämlich schon funktionierendes Grafana-Command, so, also, User, ich hab's
doch hier noch offen, oder, so, also hier Grafana-User-0 hab ich da drin stehen, ports, ports ist egal
bei Host-Networking, und Prometheus hab ich diesen Crap hier drin stehen, unter Command,
mal gucken, was das jetzt macht, ah, jetzt, schon gleich viel besser, ok, also, gehen
wir mal hin, eh, localhost 3000 ist Grafana glaub ich, jawoll, eine Runde Grafana am Start,
oh, das sieht jetzt advanceder aus als vorher, home, login, admin, admin ist glaub ich default,
don't save, new password 123456, excellent, da kommt man nie drauf, ok, data source hinzufügen,
warum sieht denn das hier so kaputt aus, data source Prometheus, localhost 9090, ja, kann
sein, 9090, konnte man das nicht noch testen, test, data source working, jawoll, save, sehr
gut, sehr gut, ok, so Chat, und jetzt müsst ihr mal weggucken, jetzt müsst ihr weggucken
Chat, jetzt trage ich nämlich das Passwort, das Passwort da drin ein, dürft ihr nicht
sehen, liegt, es ist nicht schlimm, wenn ihr es seht, ich verwende den Server eh für nix,
aber ich hab kein Bock, dass wieder irgendwelche DDoS-Jungs am Start sind oder sowas, ihr
müsst die Augen zumachen Leute, sind zu, ok nice, gehashed, gehashed ist nackt, das
wäre ja sicher, ok wir sind wieder am Start, nice, ok, also wir sind wieder da, jetzt gucken
wir mal ob der abfragt, wir können uns die Logs angucken, da machen wir jetzt das hier,
warte mal ich mach den Kram, einmal down noch, minus f glaube ich fürs löschen oder so,
jetzt machen wir nochmal ab, minus d, docker, compose, prometoys, mal gucken ob es funktioniert,
es scheint zu funktionieren, add your face to first data source, select, rctp, localhost,
99, save, jawoll, back, oh ne jetzt haben wir es doppelt drin, cacquade, ist onstream chat
broken, ne, geht immer noch, den können wir wieder löschen, wenn es schon drin ist, also
jetzt sollten wir hier eigentlich bei explore irgendwie kram drin haben, wie auch immer,
wenn der jetzt ordentlich crawlt, sollte jetzt eigentlich Sachen auftauchen dort, ne weil
ich hab das hier drinne, schauen wir mal, schauen wir mal, schauen wir mal ob da jetzt
dem kraphaner was auftaucht, man muss suchen nach, no matrix found, ich würde jetzt eins
erwarten dass das funst, ja, wir warten jetzt mal ab und machen wir auf dem server weiter,
dann können wir nachher noch nice, was hab ich denn hier im vim auf, hab ich noch den
vim auf, ne hab ich nicht, das ist ein anderer vim, ok also machen wir auf dem server weiter,
wo sind wir stehen geblieben, also wir haben jetzt den prometoys agent installiert, jetzt
müssen wir eigentlich mal zur eigentlichen Sache kommen, ich will meinem mqtt server
vorbei bringen, ich hab ne zertifikat, kadi hat das zertifikat ausgestellt, man sieht
ja das es funktioniert, ne hier gültiges zertifikat am start, alles klar, ah guck mal,
er hat, er hat, er hat discovered, ok jetzt machen wir nice das dashboard, kraphaner linux
server dashboard, da gibt es doch so ein standard overview dashboard, moment, das default dashboard,
beste, node exporter full, den da mein ich genau, copy id, zack, dashboards, wo ging das
jetzt nochmal, import, id, load, import, ja data source, import, so, excellent leute,
da haben wir unser massive dashboard, letzten 24 stunden, das bleibt ein bisschen viel letzte
5 min, so, massive dashboard, da geht jetzt den ganzen controlling und personalabteilungsleuten
einer ab, wenn dashboards am start sind, dashboards ist das allerwichtigste, egal ob da was geiles
drin steht, aber dashboards, so jetzt haben wir schonmal unser nicest dashboard für unseren
server, so muss das sein, für die stonks leute, für die ist das auch geil, die sitzen jetzt
hier da und freuen sich über das dashboard, das füllt sich jetzt übrigens gleich noch
ein bisschen mit den daten vom server, man muss sagen, das war echt relativ easy, die
meisten leute werden kraphaner und prometos daheim schon haben, die sowas machen wollen,
man installiert den node exporter, macht den reverse proxy davor und gut ist, ich muss
jetzt nochmal auf mein nzpl zeug achten, habe ich jetzt irgendwas gemacht, was ich den nzpl
noch nachbauen muss, prometos node exporter, oh ja, na klar, das caddy file, ok, das muss
ich mir aufschreiben, also was brauchen wir noch, also das caddy file muss da rein, muss
rein in nzpl, so, der preiszem twitter bot, ich weiß nicht ob ich den noch mache, das
problem beim preiszem ist, das ist eigentlich viel pflegeintensiver als ich gedacht habe,
ich weiß nicht ob ich das noch lange updatee, das nervt mich, dass ich so viel von hand
machen muss, ich hab eigentlich gedacht, das geht einfacher, muss ich mal gucken, aber
aktuell verwenden es noch viele leute, deswegen behalte ich es auch erstmal, so, nice, jetzt
haben wir poggers graph, so, nun gucken wir mal, dass wir dem mqtt server beibringen,
dass wir zertifikate verwenden wollen für die connections, so standardmäßig, eh standardmäßig
steht da glaube ich nix drinne, sondern einfach nur dieses default zeug, also sprich der lauscht
jetzt auf port, warte mal t-marks, netstat, auf port 1883 lauscht, der ist in der firewall
gar nicht frei, wie viele sind auf dem preiszem, eh um die 300.000 leute schon diesen monat,
gar nicht so übel ne, der preiszem wurde gestern auf reddit empfohlen, ernsthaft, reddit,
muss ich gucken, jeder preiszem denn überhaupt, ja funktioniert, preiszem, preiszem, die reddits
suche sackt, aber es kann durchaus sein, dass es nicht funktioniert, das ist die redditsuche
ist kacke, ah hier, hier, ok, zeig mal, sonst gibt es noch ne kleine kaufbahn, hehehe, hä,
stand da nicht eben neun antworten, achso hier, weil mittlerweile ist reddit schon ein
bisschen fail oder, guck mal hier, nice, da bin ich immer froh, wenn ich das lese sowas,
ja new reddit layout ist echt pains champ, so leute guck mal, jetzt können wir uns am
schönen dashboard erfreuen, wie poggers das aussieht für unseren server, und wir kriegen
es jetzt automatisch nach dem setup, ok, mal kurz in mich gehen, wir wollen jetzt die mqtt
konfig machen, also, mosquito, confd, touch, touch, was touchen wir, wir touchen ein, excellent
fahrstuhlmusik, touchen ein, äh, keine ahnung, ssl, conf, so, und da, ich hab mich schon angeguckt
was man da reinschreiben muss, easy, ich hab, ich copy paste jetzt, also, listener, das
ist der port auf dem er, ups, das ist der port auf dem er später verfügbar sein soll,
so, und dann, muss man ihm sagen, ca-file, cert-file, da muss ich noch gucken wo die
dinger liegen, cert-file, und key-file, und dann sollt es funktionieren, hier ist er noch
mal, serious max, wie hast du das jetzt gefunden, die reddit-suche geht bei mir nicht, oder
benutzt du, oder benutzt du alt-reddit, alt-reddit-suche, und jetzt muss ich jetzt gucken ob alt-reddit
funktioniert mit der suche, wartet mal, alt-reddit, ne geht auch nicht, ok google, wir suchen
mal bei google, preis-champ, site, site reddit, was witzig ist, ne, ah nice, was witzig ist,
reddit-suche suckt einfach so hart, ja das stimmt, das stimmt, aber ich kann halt nichts
machen wenn die seite nicht drin ist, öff bei google, so, also, weiter gehts, wie bringen
wir das dem jetzt bei, also wo hat caddy die zertifikate abgelegt ist jetzt die große frage,
suchen wir mal nach, wir fragen einfach mal google, caddy search directory location, location,
where does caddy keep certificates, exellent, genau das will ich wissen, the caddy folder,
ok also wir suchen nach dem folder der punkt caddy heißt, alles klar, slash name punkt caddy,
zeich her, wo gibts da was, gar nicht, wir suchen einfach ohne punkt, oh, glaub den punkt
hätt ich auch escapen müssen, da, da sind die zertifikate, na wer wird tatsächlich,
das ist das richtige, na wer hätte da nicht drinne gesucht, wer hätte da schon nicht
drinne gesucht, also voll intuitives verzeichnis, kommt man doch, kommt man doch locker drauf,
so sslconf, also welche, welche dateien brauchen wir da jetzt, ca-file bin ich mir noch nicht
sicher, zertfile, zertfile ist das da, und das keyfile ist das da, so und zertfile, zertfile
brauchen wir eigentlich, das let's encrypt, kann man auch zertpass nehmen, weil zertpass
ist einfach, das ist etc, ssl, da sind die ganzen ca keys, also nicht die keys, die gesigneten
ca dinger, wem vertraut wird, trusted wird, na, da ist auch let's encrypt dabei, irgendwo,
mal gucken ob es sowas gibt, also ich weiß, dass es beim kommando zeilen tool gibt, gibt
es ssl, gibt es ca pass, aber ich weiß nicht, ob es es in der serverconfig gibt, werden
wir jetzt gleich sehen, restart, restart, ok, systemctl, restart, mosquido, bam, die
chain of trust, genau, so, alles jetzt funktioniert, status, tatsächlich hat funktioniert, ok,
also von der idee her, haben wir jetzt, am start, nen webs, nen, nen, nen, na, nen mqtt
server mit zertifikat, das müssen wir jetzt allerdings mal ausbringen, ob das auch funktioniert,
und da sagen wir hier mosquito, keine ahnung, wir gucken einfach mal ob wir uns lokal dazu
subscriben können, bevor ich den port aufmache, sub, host, local, port 883, topic, alles, boah,
jetzt bin ich mal net sicher, und jetzt gibt es glaube ich ca pass und dann etc ssl certs,
das wär ja auch zu einfach, wenn das funktioniert hätte, das wär ja auch too easy, sneaky boy,
dankeschön, dankeschön für den sub, so also, etc ssl certs, wie heißt denn das richtige
letsencrypt zertifikat, letsencrypt, welches ist denn da das richtige, ach guck mal, lul,
das erste was du findest, ist sogar irgendeine mosquitokonfig oder so, nice, also was, dst
root, alles klar, und das ist die letsencrypt ca, ok, ich glaub das jetzt einfach mal, hast
du vor den preistamp irgendwann zu open sourcen, ja vielleicht, wenn ich keinen bock mehr hab
dran zu arbeiten dann, so, starten please, ssl error, dann geb ich das doch mal direkt
an, ssl error, warum, warum geht das net, anzeige ist raus, was soll das, ssl error,
hab ich den, hab ich das restarted hier schon, ssl error, ja, sehr schön, was hab ich verkehrt
gemacht, ok, wir gucken nochmal kurz rein, wie haben die dudes hier das gemacht, ja der
ssl error ist ganz toll, ja, ja genau so siehts doch bei mir aus, aber, aber ganz genau so
siehts bei mir aus, ah ich weiß was ich falsch mach leute, ich weiß was ich falsch mach,
ich, ich muss ja den domain namen verwenden, ich kann ja nicht einfach die ip verwenden
denke ich mal, test sv punkt, ah fuck, hä, moment warum geht das ohne, warum geht das
ohne, wartet mal und jetzt schick ich mal ne message und guck obs funktioniert, hopp, ja
schön dass du den wege hergefunden hast, candypancake, wie ging das jetzt nochmal, test, port, topic,
lulw, message, größer cacw, connection was lost, ok, excellent, excellent, ah moment
das ist ca pass, ca pass ist ja auch falsch, ich muss ja auch, ah jetzt funktionierts,
guck mal leute kaum macht mans richtig, kaum macht mans richtig funktionierts, ca pass
war schon richtig, guck so, offiziell, es ist offiziell bestätigt, lulw ist größer
cacw, ich mein das stehts, pass schwarz auf weit das ist einfach so, mal gucken wie viele
messages der server so ab kann, ah juckt ihn nicht, ok es funktioniert, nice, wie bring
ich dem ding jetzt noch, wie bring ich jetzt noch benutzer, benutzer, autentifizierung der
ganzen message geschichte bei, password file example, der roger, der roger ist autentifiziert,
der roger kommt weg, ok mosquito, warte mal das stand doch bei digital ocean im guide
stand das doch irgendwo drinnen hier, wir haben jetzt den guide zwar nicht, http, ne
wir haben den guide zwar nicht verfolgt, hier mosquito pass wd, alles klar, your user name,
lulw, ok password, password, bam und jetzt sagt man dem hier, ist das nicht, ist die
fault config nicht ein bisschen gefährlich, wenn da standardmäßig die user drin steht,
ah ne die user stehen ja gar nicht drin standardmäßig, ok ich hab nix gesagt, das ist einfach nur
ein beispiel gewesen und jetzt muss man das file, allow anonymous faults, password file
moskito pass wd, alles klar, machen wir, machen wir easy, benutzt der cute messenger auch cute,
paintschamp, so allow anonymous faults, übrigens leute, wie man beim vim nach unten pastet weiß
wahrscheinlich jeder, weil man p drücken muss, mit groß p pastet man nach oben, vim magic
restart, so auf restarten please, dankeschön für die subs, no limit xo 10 monate am start
und dannyboy3000 auch am start, nice dankeschön für die subs, iq plus plus plus plus plus
für den chat hier wieder, gleich, gleich platzt er, exquisite, ok sub sollte jetzt nicht mehr
funktionieren, user lulw fragt nämlich danach ein password, kann man password prompten lassen
oder so, password prompten, sub prompt password, wie ich wusste ernsthaft, die wollen dass
ich das da im klartext reinschreibe, wirklich, das ist doch für ein arschwer, wer denkt sich
das, also username, es gibt noch minus minus pw, könnt ihr euch mal entscheiden, wie das
jetzt nun mittlerweile heißt, ach das ist das gleiche, ok das ist richtig, das ist das ist
richtig oldschool, nee ich glaub das ist kein bash script, das ist irgendwie java crap oder
so, nee keine ahnung, weiß ich gar nicht in was das programmiert ist, ok es gibt witziger
weise, jetzt ich muss das ernsthaft im klartext angehen, ist das den hier in ernst, ok ich
glaub einfach dass es funktioniert leute, wir vertrauen einfach mal drauf dass es funktioniert,
ich will das jetzt nicht im klartext angeben und jetzt würde ich sagen machen wir den port
mal auf, weil ich muss ja von lokal dran kommen, leute ich hab ne idee, ich mach ne environment
variable und das übergebe ich dann da, also moment, ihr werdet jetzt ausgeplendet, wie
gesagt es ist wirklich schlimm, ich verwendet den server eh für sonst nix, gleich, so, ok
hier, zack, da sind wir wieder, hab ich das lokal installiert, ok der port ist noch nicht
auf, alles klar, passt ja auch, machen wir mal den port auf, warte mal woran listen das
jetzt nochmal 883, ok ufw allow 883 und jetzt minus p dollar mqtt pw hatte ich eben vergeben,
hä, ich hab das doch eben gesetzt, achso minus username muss ich noch machen, uolw connection
was refused, aber warum, no password specified, what, ich hab das doch eben umgebungsvariable
gemacht mit dem kack password, ah ich bin doof leute, ich bin dumm, ich hab mich verschrieben,
ich hab's, ich hab's, ah lol jetzt hab ich password geleaked, password leaked, jetzt
kann ichs auch eingeben, es eh wurscht ich verwende das für sonst nirgendswo was, so,
funktioniert, exellent, so kann ich auch subben, passwor, hä, moment, sub, password, music,
salami icq, jetzt funktionierts leute, alles gut, exellent, jetzt muss ich das password
changen, perfekt, wobei nee ich muss das password net changen, weil ich mach einfach das wieder
aus, und es kann eh nix großartig passieren, so, ähm, dann deleteen wir noch 443, ups,
warte mal, man konnte doch auch sagen allow, man konnte, konnte man nicht einfach sowas
hier sagen delete allow 443 und delete allow, ja genau so geht das, nee, https, http, a,
ja, na, jetzt komm ma jetzt die firewall nehm ich wieder dicht, ja gut, ähm, das password,
ich hab einfach die letzten drei emotes in meinem dashboard genommen, die letzten drei
emotes sind, music, salami, icq, ich hab irgendwas gebraucht, was man nicht erraten
kann so auf instant, da passiert ja nix großartig, das ist ein temporärer server mit irgendwie
nicht, mit unsinnigen dingern, also ja selbst wenn einer das password jetzt hat, bringt
ihm gar nix im endeffekt, so, also, das funktioniert alles, was wir jetzt noch eine sache, die
ich jetzt noch nicht kapiert hab, also das passt so, das ist auch, das ist alles in ordnung
so wie es ist, das einzige was wir noch machen müssen ist, wenn das password erneuert wird
vom caddy, dann muss ich den, den mosquito neu starten, weil der lädt es ja nicht automatisch
neu und ich hab gelesen, dass den reload, den reload tut es nicht fürs zertifikat,
es muss ein restart sein, es muss ein restart sein, das macht eigentlich unser nicest dashboard,
oh unser dashboard, exquisite dashboard, oder, das ist nicht nice, achso ich hab die file
wohl wieder zu gemacht, ja jetzt geht das dashboard kaputt, so, es heißt eigentlich
für die sache, könnte ich so machen, ich mach einfach einmal nachts einen neustart über
den cron shop, fertig, das ist zwar nicht die schöne variante, was der nodexporter,
das ist das standard, das offizielle dashboard für den prometos nodexporter, da ist einfach,
da ist einfach alles was es gibt, alles was es gibt mit drinne, salami ist so tost, dass
es bei ffz und beta twitch tv und so gelöscht wurde, also man könnte doch jetzt im prinzip,
die ganz easy variante wäre einfach cron daily eintrag zu machen, da sagen wir mal irgendwie
mqtt das ganze zu nennen, bin, bash und dann einfach das reinschreiben, fertig, das wars,
das ist zwar nicht schön, da wird einmal nachts die verbindung gekappt, aber das ist für
meine presence detection jetzt nicht wirklich relevant, warum muss ich neu starten, falls
das zertifikat geupdatet wurde, also wenn caddy das zertifikat update bekommt der mqtt
server das nicht mit, man könnte das sicherlich schöner machen, oh leute ich hab ne idee,
ich weiß wie wirs machen, wir gucken ob es heute gechanged wurde und wenn es heute gechanged
wurde, dann restarten wir mosquito, das ist doch schöner, ok also stat, stat auf den,
ist eigentlich egal, auf das zert, so, genau das ist eigentlich ne gute idee, ich baue
das in den cron shop ein, wenn es heute gechanged wurde das zertifikat, dann startet der den
neu, das ist doch gut, es läuft daily also an irgendeinem tag ist es auf jeden fall,
da wird es nicht jede nacht neu gestartet, das ist ne schönere variante oder, viel zu
viel auffallen das ist kein wirklich nutz, wieso hat es keinen nutz, dann bricht einmal
nachts die verbindung nicht ab, da kann ich übertragen, dass ich im bett liege, wie macht
man das jetzt eigentlich gescheit in nem script, test file, das kann test, test kann das doch
oder, file, modified oder so, modi, modified, bash if file modified today, stack overflow
driven programming, ah yes, stack overflow weiß mir da bescheid, das ist immer geil,
warum selbst überlegen, wenn man einfach stack overflow suchen kann, marvin sonnt schreibt
hallo, malzeit, ich habe mich bei dell für eine ausbildung zum physi beworben, da ich
aber schon eine ausbildung zum mechatroniker habe und sehr viel ahnung von computern allgemein
habe, habe ich die von dell mir direkt eine feststellung, das ist doch nice, also wenn
ich dazu beigetragen habe, ist das poggers, finde ich auch poggers, das ist nice, aber
ich muss mal dazu sagen, vielleicht machen die das auch nicht ganz aus reiner nix, liebe
und wollen dich für ein apple und ein eye beschäftigen, also was ich immer sagen muss
unterm strich, einfach immer mal gucken, dass man sich nicht verarschen lässt, danke für
den sub, du kannst auch das pitfall, oh jetzt wirds aber, jetzt wirds aber advanced, weiß
gar nicht, wo das liegt, war, irgendwas, so ist das gut, so ist das top, only modification
time, innerhalb der letzten sind das was, tage oder minuten, minuten sind das, modify date,
ok gucken wir mal ob das stimmt, gucken wir mal ob das stimmt, gehen wir mal in das verzeichnis
rein und jetzt, was, nein, sehe ich das jetzt nicht, achso älter als, älter als, ok, minus,
ah yes, also dateien die quasi, innerhalb der letzten 120 minuten, genau innerhalb der
letzten 5, ok, der, der letzten, keine ahnung, was ist denn ein tag, 3600 minutes, day, alter
der sound wieder, moment, moment, moment, day, aha, 1440 minuten, exquisite, das brauchen
wir ja Leute, easy as fuck, so, so brauchen wir das, zack, zack, ok, das schreiben wir
jetzt in den cron shop rein, if, if, find das mit dem test brauchen wir übrigens gar
nicht, das mit dem test brauchen wir eigentlich gar nicht oder, der return code reicht doch
vom find, was hat, was hat das, was hat das find für den return code, wenn es was findet
und was hat, wenn es nichts findet, den test braucht man glaube ich gar nicht, find findet
was, hat return code 130, na ok, meinetwegen, so und jetzt war es woran, achso, ähm, und
jetzt wo er nix findet, 0, ok, passt doch, also if, erstmal in das verzeichnis wechseln,
so, find, find, hier das da, ne ne, minus, minus 1440 war es, so, find, also wenn find
irgendwas findet, dann starten wir neu, ansonsten machen wir eigentlich nix, ah ne, äh, nicht
dann, so, fertig, das sollte jetzt von der Idee her funktionieren, 1337, ja dann, das
stimmt voll logisch ja nicht mehr, dann lassen wir das mal laufen, lassen wir das mal laufen,
run parts, zikron, ich glaube so ging das, funktioniert leute, funktioniert und er startet
neu, deswegen hängt das jetzt so lang, ja by the way, wer mal cron shops manuell testen
manuell so, status, status, wurde gestartet vor 11 sekunden, ok, cron shop passt, alles
klar, easy, easy, ok, also im endeffekt was müssen wir jetzt noch in ansible übertragen,
das caddy file, die mosquito config und den cron shop, oder das wars doch, oder hab ich
doch irgendwas vergessen, ich glaube das war alles, man kann auch die systemzeit ändern,
allerdings weiß ich gar nicht wann daily standardmäßig läuft, ich glaube um 3 oder
so, sehr schön, sehr schön, so das ergibt hier alles den ufw einschalten, ufw ssh erlauben,
so, ach moment was mach ich denn da, die musik ist wieder nice, so ufw so updaten, mosquito
installieren, caddy installieren, caddy starten, alles klar, ok, ok, jetzt müssen wir noch
das caddy file reinschreiben, ich automatisier grad den serveraufbau, hier, also wir haben
jetzt erst immer hingekriegt, dass es an sich funktioniert, also moment wir brauchen das
caddy file, brauchen wir, und dann testen wir auch mal ob es funktioniert, was wir da
gemacht haben, also das caddy file, ups, hab ichs geöffnet, firewall ist zu, das kann nicht
funktionieren, also, wie krieg ich jetzt in das caddy file ordentlich was rein, caddysetup
reverse proxy, also ich muss in das caddy file ja dieses, dieses ding hier reinkriegen,
pass, etc caddy caddy, recax, insert, after, line, moment, kann ich da nicht einfach,
was, was ist line in file, what the, was hab ich da das letzte mal gemacht, inside, after,
kann ich nicht einfach config file reinschreiben, hardcoded, ansible, file, wie übertrag ich
den kram hier jetzt, file, ja, content, access time, ich will einfach nur file content hinschreiben,
ja den template, template weiß ich, aber geht das nicht einfacher, ich will eigentlich
kein extra template file machen, oder, oder heißt das nur template, multiple file line,
block in file, was ist das denn, insert, update, remove, block of multi line text, genau das
will ich haben, template, template braucht man glaube ich ein extra file, wobei, ist
das, das mit template ist doch eigentlich fast besser, das mit dem template ist doch
eigentlich fast, fast noch, fast noch besser, welche rechte brauchen das caddy file, gut,
ok, das ist ja einfach, dann machen wir das doch mal hier rein, also caddy file brauchen
wir, aber machen wir mit dem template, glaube ich, zinniger, also template, source, ja templates,
bezieht sich das auf das verzeichnis, in dem ich es ausführe, oder muss ich sowas hier
machen, source, wobei ich kann, ich mach einfach sowas hier, ich hab ja aktuell nur ein, ich
glaube großschreibt man, ich hab ja aktuell nur ein verzeichnis, wo das alles drin ist,
so destination, etc, caddy, caddy file, das ganze gehört root, gruppe root und 644 passt,
so, dann legen wir mal ein file an, so, haben wir nämlich den content, haben wir es schon
hier drinne, genau das da wollen wir haben, ich glaube, das muss, glaube ich, das muss
funktionieren, so, also das caddy file haben wir jetzt drin, die mosquito config brauchen
wir auf jeden fall, die war etc, etc, mosquito, confd, sslconf, das geile ist, wenn man das
einmal gemacht hat, habe ich auf, ups, habe ich auf einen blick gleich, was auf dem server
drauf ist und wie es funktioniert und ich kann es einfach wieder hinstellen, so, wir
wollen das file anlegen, caddy file, source, nennen wir es einfach mal so, root root, stimmt
das, root root, alles klar, caddy enable können wir hier nach, so, also, etc, confd,
ssl links, sslconf, die müssen wir anlegen, sslconf, hatte man doch hier gerade, oder
auch nicht, habe ich da nicht reingeguckt, genau das da, so, und das wars, glaube ich,
sogar schon, kommt der ganze, achso, der cronchop, der cronchop noch, mosquito, habe ich irgendwas
vergessen, außer dem cronchop jetzt, glaube ich nicht, so, ansible cron, wie machen wir
mit ansible den cron, das war doch auch relativ easy, hatte ich doch schon oft, kann man auch
einfach sagen, daily, genau, special time, daily, special time, hier haben sie ein Beispiel
genau, so, das mosquito password file, ah genau, da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht,
sehr gut, chat, big brain, wie immer, so, create, so, so, der cronchop, den haben wir
hier irgendwo hier drinnen stehen, achso, kann ich inline den cronchop, script reinschreiben,
was ist das, ach hier, job, guck mal da, exquisite, jetzt wirds, das war mal so, hier, Achtung,
alles schön inline reinfummeln, ah yes, wobei, nee, der führt das doch bestimmt standardmäßig
bashmäßig aus oder, cd, easy, easy, wir machen das jetzt alles one line, moment, man kann
das doch bestimmt multiline machen oder, man kann das doch bestimmt multiline, wie ging
multiline noch mal in, in yaml, das war doch so ein komisches Sonderzeichen, irgendwie
sowas da, yaml, multiline, war das ein pipe, sowas da, ne, ah ja, ah ja, pipe, pipe, ich
will lineprojects preserven, ok, wie ging das jetzt noch mal, pipe, key, pipe und dann,
einfach so dahinter, exquisite, massive code, mal gucken was da rauskommt, mal gucken was
da rauskommt jetzt, so, jetzt haben wir den cronjob, muss man es einmal einrücken, ja
tatsächlich, ok, jetzt haben wir den cronjob zum, zum neu starten, jetzt fehlt uns nur
noch das password-file, jetzt fehlt nur noch das password-file, das password-file gibt's
unter etc, mosquito, pwd, passwd, weil, da, das war mal ein template, ich muss, ich muss
den moskito, ich muss den moskito danach noch neu starten, so, und jetzt kommt das template,
kopieren wir hier gleich mit hin, passwd, das muss man auf jeden fall noch ein bisschen
ordentlicher machen, nachconf, passwd, und jetzt, wie restartet man den service, service,
ich kann bestimmt einfach sagen restart zum schluss dann, service, restart and so, special
time hab ich nicht gemacht, ahja, ahja, lol, beim reboot, so, restart, ok, state restart,
state restart, gut, ich würd sagen jetzt haben wir alles, alles drin, wir, wir, wir
löschen den, ich hab nix vergessen glaube, wir löschen den server mal und gucken ob
das jetzt funktioniert den automatisch aufzubauen, da bin ich ja mal huge gespannt, ah, moment,
ich geh nochmal kurz in mich, ob ich irgendwas vergessen hab, moment, warum ist meine bash
history so kurze, ach ne, ist es gar nicht, ich hab da, ich hab ja das t-max gehabt dann,
ne egal, also wird schon, wird schon passen, so, server, server, neu bauen, hetzner, komm
her, recreate, rebuild, ubuntu 20.4, rebuild, rebuild, ok, mal gucken, erstmal den key wieder
rausschmeißen, ah, ich hab noch was vergessen, leute, ich hab noch was vergessen, ich muss
die ports aufmachen, warte mal, ich muss, ich muss die ports aufmachen, ich erlaube,
ich erlaube http, httdings, ich muss auch port 883, äh, 883 erlauben, so, also von der
idee her, lasst mal überlegen, ergibt das irgendwie Sinn was wir hier machen, wir erlauben
ssh, dass wir uns nicht aussperren, dann erlauben wir http, https, mqtt, dann sagen wir firewall
ist aktiv, dann machen wir updates mit paketen, installieren standardsachen, installieren mqtt,
fast, aktivieren den ganzen kram, dann installieren wir den webserver, auch alles klar, ähm, ich
glaub einen cutty restart brauch ich am ende noch, dann installieren wir, genau hier installieren
wir den cutty, dann machen wir das cutty file hin, ne hier mach ich das enable restart cutty,
alles klar, danach mach ich die configs für mqtt hin, ich enable den kram, äh, restart,
restart ich mqtt und mach am ende noch einen conchop hin, ok, mal gucken ob das funktioniert,
ich bin ja mal, ich bin ja mal gespannt, ok, serverlogin funktioniert schon wieder, alles
klar, dann führen wir den kram mal aus, jetzt bin ich echt gespannt ob das klappt, ansieble,
ansieble, bam, oh, rip, ok, das geht mit der syntag schonmal nicht, ähm, nein, das heißt
ich brauch für jede firewall-riegel was eigenes, kann so firewall-riegel nicht in einem machen,
ok, ansieble ufw, ufw, bin ja bestimmt nicht der einzige der das problem hat, loop, oh,
jetzt wirds advanced leute, what the fuck, ah, oh, big brain time alter, ok, big brain
time, mal gucken ob das funktioniert, und was jetzt item, so, ja, das ist aber die loop
wird für alles funktionieren denke ich mal, ok, komm, postchamp, postchamp, ok, das funktioniert,
ja, das ist ok, aber es hat funktioniert, guck mal, guck mal, der hat ne, der hat ne
schleife gemacht, ok, wir sollen quoteen sagt er, wir quoteen, aber quote ich die anderen
dinge auch einfach aus prinzip, changed, ok, jetzt macht der update upgrade, das dauert
jetzt halb minute, so, in der zwischenzeit, ich guck mal kurz ein paar questions die ich
übersehen hab, ups, ich kann das eigentlich von hier machen, so, wo ist das pepega board,
da ist das pepega board, also, zeig mal her, was hab ich übersehen, ubuntu version, ah,
also nix, oh, oh, das geht gar nicht weiter, aber das hatten wir doch schon, machst du
nochmal ne room tour, ja, wenn ich die möglichkeit hab mein heimautomatisierungszeug zu zeigen
ohne dass ich so viel leake, und wenn ich aufgeräumt hab, dann mach ich ne room tour, das hab ich
noch nicht gelesen, aber bin ich mal gespannt, hatten wir, ja, für presence detection, ja,
cool idee, das hatten wir schon, das hatten wir schon, wir auch schon, hatten wir alles
schon, nee, suchen wir, suchen wir glaube grad keine, und auch keinen, ja gut, ITIL Geschichten
ist immer so ein Ding, da stehen sie auch alle, alle stehen drauf das Wort ITIL zu sagen,
aber wirklich sinnvoll was machen, so haben sie halt dann keiner bock drauf, guck mal hier
scheint alles zu funktionieren, bin ich ja mal echt gespannt ob es danach tut, ja, die
war günstig und die passt für meine heimautomatisierungs sachen, wie gesagt, pork bunn, aber das sackt
eigentlich, wie gesagt, bei meinem domain registrar hab ich, oh, oh, oh Mist, warum?
ich hab's geschafft bei meinem domain registrar gebannt zu werden, systemctl status, was hat
der, wie, warum nicht, warum, warum, hab ich das vorher nicht erst enabled oder was?
was hat der für probleme, vielleicht sind die zertifikate noch nicht da
erstmal kurz gucken, ob die ufw regeln stimmen, ja, geht, test srv, ok, der caddy geht auch
nicht, ok, da ist irgendwas schief gelaufen, da ist irgendwas schief gelaufen, ok, caddy
install, install caddy, caddy file, enable, start caddy, ok, der caddy läuft, caddy läuft,
alles gut, status, status, ist auch alles da, etc, caddy, caddy file, auch alles da, woran
hängt's jetzt genau, woran hängt's jetzt genau, was hat der für, ist der nodexporter
nicht drauf, doch, ne, ufw ist offen, 80443, warum geht das jetzt nicht?
äh, moment, hab ich den restart an der falschen stelle, hab ich den restart an der falschen
stelle, enable and start, ich glaube ich muss restart machen, ähm, ich glaube ich muss
nen restart machen, weil caddy schon läuft, caddy läuft nach dem installen schon, deswegen
funktioniert das nicht, ich muss den, ich muss den enableen, moment, moment, moment, wo sind
wir, ja, kann ich hier, kann ich hier sagen, state, restart, geht das, restarted, das müsste
doch, das müsste doch eigentlich funktionieren, by the way, warum, warum ist das service und
bei dem anderen ist es systemd, ich glaube jetzt bin ich, jetzt glaube ich bin ich, cadd,
ich glaube ich muss hier auch systemd nehmen, wenn man zu viel copy pasted, so restart, restart,
ok, das ergibt jetzt Sinn, ok, ich führe es nochmal aus, na jetzt macht er den ganzen
kram nochmal, aber es geht jetzt schneller, weil das ist ja schon alles durch, aber ich
bin begeistert mit der schleife, das ist viel cooler als in puppet gelöst, puppet sagt
was schleifen angeht, das hat er ja schon alles gemacht, hat er auch schon gemacht, hat er
auch schon gemacht, hat er auch schon gemacht, jetzt, post jump, ja, ja, ok, er restarted,
er ist ja schonmal weiter gekommen als vorher, was, oh mein cron chop ist kaputt, alles andere
funktioniert angeblich, ja, ja, funktioniert, wie sieht es mit dem pub aus, ok, mosquito
funktioniert auch, start at task, das ist eine gute Idee, ja, was für schmerzen hat
er mit meinem cron chop, start at task, ah das ist gut, das ist perfekt, das brauche
ich, ich will starten, ok, was hat er für schmerzen, was, bad minute errors in cronfile,
ich habe doch gesagt daily, daily, daily, special, special time, ja das habe ich doch
so drinne, was, an was stört er, was stört er sich jetzt, das ist doch genau wie es im
beispiel ist, oder stört er sich an dem multiline, oder stört er sich an dem multiline, ah, ok,
er stört sich an meinem, in welcher, ah ja, ok, er stört sich an meinem multiline script,
das ist natürlich doof, was soll das denn, anzeige ist raus, vielleicht daran, dass ich
da bash reingeschrieben habe, kann man das, ich glaube das kann man gar nicht multiline
machen an der stelle, ich glaube das ist überhaupt nicht erlaubt, dass man das multiline macht,
ich glaube das geht überhaupt nicht, ok, moment, wir machen jetzt exquisite, exquisite one line
raus, if, then, glaube es muss man, es wird immer schöner, wird immer schöner, immer
schöner, so, und jetzt, ah yes, jetzt funktioniert es, guckt, jetzt tut es, one tap, genau, also
hier geht kein multiline drinne, das muss alles in einer zeile sein, so wie es aussieht,
soll mal gucken, ob sich das ganze jetzt auch ausführen lässt, was ich hier gebaut habe,
ich hab nix gesagt, moment, if, oh Gott, wie mach ich das, wie mach ich das, one line
muss ich hier, oh ne, wie geht das in bash, fuck, bash, if, one line, ah wieso, das hab
ich doch richtig gemacht, ach, moment, hä, wait a minute, so rum, das ist ja auch verkehrt,
was ich hier gemacht hab, so, so ist richtig, one, so, ergibt es jetzt Sinn, was ich hier
gebaut hab, bam, jetzt funktioniert's, excellent, okay, Hetzner, Server wird nochmal platt gemacht
und nochmal aufgebaut, excellent, excellent, ausloggen, und jetzt läuft's durch, easy,
easy win, ich hab nur noch einen Bedenken, warum es nicht funktionieren könnte, und zwar,
dass die Zeit hier dazwischen zu kurz ist, guck mal, ich mach hier das caddy-file hin,
und hier restarte ich caddy, so, hier fängt caddy jetzt an, sich ein Zertifikat zu holen,
und das dauert ja 20 Sekunden, bis caddy sich ein Zertifikat geholt hat, das heißt,
ich müsste eigentlich hier dazwischen so ne Art sleep machen, wie mach ich einen sleep
in ansible, Pause, pause-champ, pause, jawoll, das hier 200 Leute, wir haben ja nicht nur
ansible programmiert, wir haben ja die ganze MQTT-Geschichte ausprobiert, pause für seconds,
geht bestimmt auch, oder, seconds, ja, seconds für, weiß ich, 30, wait for thirds, so, was
ist eigentlich das für ne monkaS-musik, oh, ist besser, gut, ok, ist das server rebuilded,
ok, server ist rebuilded, exellent, ok, dann hauen wir mal drauf, jetzt 30 Sekunden warten
auf Zertifikat, ok, plus RNG, ach ne, gibt's ja nicht mehr, bam, wäre es nicht sinnvoller
darauf zu warten, dass die Zertifikat-Dateien alle da sind, kann das, kann das, I-notify
oder so warten, wait for file, ah, oh, das ist nice, ok, file, to wait for records match
a string to be present in a file, wait for a file, oh, das ist cool, ja, das ist nice,
das brauche ich, das brauche ich, das ist viel besser, viel, viel besser, wait for, das
ist genau, wait for und dann gebe ich das Zertifikat, den Zertifikats-Fahrt an, so ist das top, ok,
ansiebele, aber jetzt breche ich nicht ab zwischendurch, ich kann das übrigens nicht
mehr so oft machen, ich hätte let's encrypt, hätte ich auf die staging-server stellen
sollen, weil sonst laufe ich jedenfalls ins rate-limit, ich weiß nicht wieviel Zertifikate
man am Tag für ein Subdomain machen kann, irgendwie 20 oder so, dann sagt let's encrypt,
ok ne, jetzt mach erst mal, mach erst mal langsam, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ne das geht, es gibt auch globale limits, also man kann es bei let's encrypt gar nicht
so sehr übertreiben, ok, wait, jetzt macht der caq-wait für das Zertifikat, schauen
wir mal ob das lang genug wartet, wo, wo war das nochmal?
share, caddy, caddy, nee, bar, lib, caddy, local, share, certs, ok es ist alles da, alter
monke s-musik aber auch viel besser ok ok leute es scheint alles zu funktionieren
excellent, fehlerfrei durchgelaufen, test, srv, matrix sind da, jawoll, der nodexport
ist am start, zertifikat ist gültig und mqtt published auch, nice, easy, server aufgebaut,
fertig funst, so der nächste schritt ist jetzt erstmal zu gucken, dass man es etwas schöner
vielleicht noch macht, aber das ist schon mal poggers, das ist schon mal nice, alles
funktioniert, so hübsch, hübsch ist das ganze schon mal prinzipiell gar nicht was
hier gebaut hat, aber es funktioniert, ja übrigens hab ich euch, ja hab ich schon,
ich hab's ja auch mal bei meinem domain registrar voll übertrieben, also ich bin bei einem
ultra low budget domain registrar, bei denen hier hab ich meine domains registriert, die
sind billig aber sonst eigentlich nix, so und das problem ist, die haben keine dns api,
also sprich wenn man über, wenn man seine, wenn man lets encrypt dns zertifizierung machen,
dns challenge machen will, da muss man über die dns api geheime secrets dahinter hinterlegen
dass es funktioniert, so und ich hab mir gedacht ok, wenn mein anbieter keine api hat, dann
scripte ich das einfach mit einem headless chrome und ich hab's im headless chrome gescriptet
und hatte da nen fehler drin und dann hab ich irgendwie 500 mal mich versucht einzuloggen
und dann haben sie mich gesperrt, aber es kam noch besser, danach hab ich den support
angeschrieben und hab gesagt ah leute tut mir leid habt ihr vielleicht ne api und am
magens haben sie geschrieben nein wir haben keine api und wir mögen nicht dass unser
webinterface gecrawlt wird, hab ich gesagt ja ja ok ok ich machs nie wieder, entsperrt
mich mal, haben sie mich entsperrt und dann wollte ich das scroller script anpassen, also
dieses headless chrome script anpassen für was anderes und hab zwei tage später oder
nen tag später vergessen die domain zu ändern und hab ichs ausgeführt 500 mal wieder versucht
einzuloggen und wieder gebannt, nochmal support angeschrieben, support nochmal doof geguckt
hab mich nochmal entbandt, krelax 15 monat dankeschön für die prime subscription, aber
ich bin begeistert, das ist nice, jetzt weiß ich, komm mal aber das hat einen riesen vorteil
es ist zwar kein schönes ansible hier aber ich weiß alles was auf dem solver drauf ist
und ich weiß auch genau wenn der mal nicht geht nach was ich gucken muss, so jetzt mal
ne frage an die ansible profis, wie würde man das jetzt schöner machen, also wie würde
man das jetzt zum beispiel mit den ganzen also mit den templates machen, da würde man
wahrscheinlich nen template ordner machen oder würde man nen role ordner erstellen,
role, visible role, man quasi sagt genau roles und dann roles mqtt server oder irgendwie
sowas, ne aber ich hab ja keine rollen, ich hab im endeffekt einfach nen kompletten, ne
komplette server konfig, fertig, macht es sinn, macht es sinn playbooks nach server
zu ordnen, ne aber wie soll ich das hier gescheit verrollifizieren, erstmal ne ufw machen, dann
package installation machen, das hier ist halt das komplette setup für einen server,
ich weiß nicht wie ich das sonderlich schön verrollen kann, willst mich rollen alter, also
machts vielleicht sinn, so was hab ich mir auch gedacht, dass man sowas macht wie templates
und dann für den hostname, also irgendwie sagt keiner templates, dann test srv und jetzt
diese sslconf und passwd und das cari file, dass man das jetzt nach templates verschiebt,
ich mein das ist schonmal ein bisschen ordentlicher, das sind templates, also ich benutze zumindest
templates ohne da was einzusetzen, was aber eigentlich auch schon, ja das könnte man
natürlich auch noch schöner machen, was mir auch überhaupt nicht gefällt ist das
hier, ah guckt euch mal den cronjob an alter, das ist ordentlich gut, also asher, also asher
ist so ein ding für sich, ich kenne asher über zwei sachen, einmal mit terraform, das
ist ja auch quasi ähnlich von der config her, plus ist halt, ich sag mal so, ansible
ist eher so das tool wo man sagt wie genau ein server konfiguriert soll, terraform ist
eher für die infrastruktur, oder eben halt dieses asher cli für bash, auf der microsoft
schulung wollten sie uns unbedingt überreden dazu, dass man das in powershell macht, ich
wollte nicht, ich will das in bash machen, ich mach das später auch in bash oder in
den ordentlichen linux shell, ich will das nicht unter powershell machen, geht mal fort
powershell, ja wo, leute ich frage mich ernsthaft, was ist der sinn von diesem cronmodul, weil
ich könnte doch einfach hier hergehen, ein datei anlegen, sagen wir mal irgendwie mqtt,
cron oder so, dann machen wir den kram rein, bin, bash, dann machen wir hier den kram mal
mit ordentlich zeilumbruch wieder rein, und jetzt anstatt den cronjob kopiere ich einfach
die datei dahin, das ist doch eigentlich viel sinnvoller, nach etc, cron, daily, mqtt, cron,
so, dann sag ich mod 7.0.0, und gut ist, also wenn ich es einfach nur daily ausführen will,
ist das doch wahrscheinlich sogar noch die einfache variant, ey 7.7.7 muss das nicht
sein, cron muss eigentlich nur root ausführbar sein, oder?
Achja, source, genau, source ist nicht pass-wd, sondern source ist in dem fall ja template,
muss man das dann auch so angeben, template, test-sav, kann man, hey leute, es gibt, man
kann das doch, man kann doch hier bestimmt, irgendwelche variablen reinschreiben, oder?
host, host gibt es doch garantiert als variablen, irgend sowas wie current, current-host oder
sowas, test-sav, mqtt.cron, ja ich muss mir das mal in ruhe angucken, wie man das schön,
schön modularer macht, ja, ich habe ja mittlerweile einen ganz guten überblick, was eingebaut
ist, aber so die praktische anwendung fehlt mir noch ein bisschen, von, habe ich templates
genannt, oh templates, excellent, dann hier auch noch hin, überall, überall muss das
davor, bäm, bäm, aber schön ist es nett,
der schrott die linchen, wie würdest du es denn jetzt machen, also, würdest du das so
hinschreiben, oder über das ansible-cron-modul, das mit dateien wieder schwer los werden,
ist in puppet übrigens auch so, das problem bei diesen ganzen config-managements ist,
was alle gemein haben, die können nur das verwalten, was definiert ist, also, wenn man
zum beispiel, das hat bei uns auch schon mal ordentlich probleme gemacht, bei certifikaten
glaube ich war das auch, und zwar bei puppet ist es auch so, wenn du dem sagst, leg eine
datei hier hin, und du löscht das dann aus der config, dann bleibt die datei für immer
auf dem server liegen, weil es ist ja aus der config raus, die fasst das nicht mehr
an, eigentlich müsste man für jede datei, die man hinzufügt, später noch mal, noch
einen eintrag machen, wo man sie auf löschen setzt, das ist ein bisschen problematisch
bei diesem ganzen config-management, deswegen finde ich den cloud-ansatz, systeme einfach
zu professionieren und gut ist, und wenn man sie ändern will, quasi neu zu erstellen,
besser, dann ist nämlich alles weg, du musst übrigens nicht template-host-file schreiben,
was, ach so, echt jetzt, es reicht, wenn ich so, reicht es, wenn ich so schreibe, reicht
das dann wirklich, also der guckt dann selbst nach templates und name von dem ding, sollte,
können wir mal ausprobieren, ist das ding wieder da, ich hab's wieder resettet, so also
was kann man, was könnte man jetzt hier nochmal so auf die schnelle, auf die schnelle bisschen
schöner machen, also, so die ufw-geschichten, die ufw-geschichten machen wir alles in eins,
wo wir gerade dabei sind, kann das, ssh, ufw-allow-mqtt, versteht er, versteht er nicht, ok, muss
man so machen, so, dann kann man das schon mal rausschmeißen, so, ufw-allow-http-https-ssh-qtt,
schon mal ein bisschen kürzer, dann haben wir hier die Schleife drum herum, default,
kann man das da noch mit reinschreiben, hat jemand einen Plan, kann man das noch mit reinschreiben
hier, state-enabled, policy-deny, rule-allow, so alles in einem, was anstatt loop wäre
with-items, wisst ihr mal, man lernt, man lernt, aha, aber wo ist denn der Unterschied,
es sind rein so taktische Dinge, oder, so, ja ich kann mich aussperren, wenn das fehlt
schlägt, ne, beziehungsweise, wenn er das zuerst macht, wenn er das zuerst macht, dann
kann er dann, den da nicht mehr mit ausführen, das ist, ja, das glaub ich echt keine gute
Idee, glaub so ist, glaub so ist sinnvoller, aber, aber das kann man zusammenfassen, geh
ich mal von aus, so, den installer können wir auch zusammenfassen, so, so, so, so, so,
so, also wie macht man das, wie macht man das mit venus, also, 1 linear, 2 Democrats,
So, jetzt haben wir das ein bisschen abgekürzt hier, das ist alles in einem.
Das machen wir später, aber erstmal den ganzen Kadi-Kram installieren. Und das können wir auch
zusammenfassen. Guck mal, hier sag ich restarted und hier kann ich sagen enable einfach auch yes.
So, jetzt haben wir es schon ein bisschen aufgeräumt. So, einmal lasse ich es noch
laufen und gucke, ob es noch funktioniert. Oder war es das für heute?
Was? Oh, okay, jetzt haben wir wieder verkackt. Install packages. Was hat das für ein Problem?
Also install und upgrade geht nicht in einem? Sehe ich das richtig? Okay,
ich muss es kurz mal zurückkopieren. Wo hatte ich denn das? Okay, das muss man zuerst machen.
Update, upgrade, dann kann ich das hier aber rauslassen. Ja, jetzt funktioniert das auch.
Also, was war hier mit Englisch? Machen wir Englischklausur mit dem Thema Artificial
Intelligence. Gibt es ja immer wieder Diskussionen und Disziplinen über die Zukunft. Was denkst
du, wird Künstliche Intelligenz in vielen Jahren schlauer als der Mensch sein und viele Aufgaben
übernehmen? Also, ich glaube nicht, dass irgendwelche Terminator Geschichten dabei rumkommen. Viele
Aufgaben auf jeden Fall. Ob wir im Bereich Roboter oder so irgendwie Fortschritte machen,
dass dann quasi in Altenpflegeheimen und so Roboter am Start sind, mal gucken. Das wäre
auf jeden Fall Anwendungsgebiet. Die Japaner sind ja schon dabei. Kennt noch jemand diese
japanische Altersheim-Robbe? Diese das weiße Fell-Ding, was sie versucht haben, in Altersheim
einzusetzen. Also sowas, sowas könnte ich mir vorstellen. Aber wo es auf jeden Fall, denke
ich, massiv Gas geben wird das Ganze, wenn wir es irgendwie auf die Reihe kriegen, dass
die Dinger sich selbst optimieren können. Ich weiß, das geht jetzt so ein bisschen in
Richtung Terminator, aber wenn wir es schaffen, dass Programme andere Abläufe optimieren können.
So ein bisschen in die Richtung, wie das diese AI learns to play Mario Sachen machen. Weil
wenn man es mal genau nimmt, das ist ja eigentlich eine AI, die andere Software, also Bedienung
von anderer Software optimiert. Mario läuft auf dem Emulator und die AI bedient quasi
diesen Emulator. Ich glaube, da werden wir auf jeden Fall massig Fortschritte machen
und das wird auch richtig viel bringen. Und das wird die Sache dann auch mal schieben,
das wird die Sache dann auch extrem beschleunigen, wenn die Dinger sich auf diese Art und Weise
verbessern können. Ich glaube aber, dass es im Endeffekt für uns eigentlich nur gut
sein kann. Und das erste, was es eh geben wird, sind irgendwelche Roboter Weifuß oder
so. Man darf die Weeps nicht unterschätzen. Sind überall. Ah, ich hab's wieder verkackt.
Das stimmt nicht, der Chat hat mich jebaited. Der Chat hat gesagt, er finde die Datei automatisch
oder findet die Datei nicht automatisch. Also, ich muss doch Templates schreiben. Templates.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert. Ah ne, ich hätte ab Task starten sollen. Das
muss er das nicht nochmal machen. Wobei, passiert dir eh nix. Ist ja schon alles durch. Ja,
das halten sie, kenn ich. Die, die sich dann oben auf die Wand gestellt haben oder so.
Es geht jetzt übrigens gleich wieder kaputt. Ich sag's nur. Aber es sollte einen Schritt
später kaputt gehen, wenn ich's richtig erkannt hab. Ja. Ja. Nice. Nice. Also, das muss tatsächlich
überall vor die Templates davor. Natürlich bisschen doof. Ey, ich hab gesagt, ich hab
gesagt, du sollst aborten, Alter. Mach mal. Jetzt hängt er. Okay, aber das Ansible Zeug
funktioniert. Ich find das echt nice. Ich muss mich da noch ein bisschen mehr mit beschäftigen,
wie man das schöner modularer machen kann. Weil zum Beispiel, das da will ich ja auf
jedem Server machen. Also nicht das da, nur SSH. Das will ich auf jedem Server machen.
Das da will ich auch auf jedem Debian Server machen, wenn's neu ist. Das da auch. Das
da auch, bis halt auf das letzte. Das muss ich mir mal angucken. Also, das kann man bestimmt
richtig, richtig cool machen. Nee, jetzt ist vorbei hier. Ist abgekackt, Leute. So, ich
lösch den Hetzener Server mal. By the way, soll ich euch mal zeigen, was mich der Preischamp
gekostet hat in diesem Monat. Aber da ist die ganze Entwicklung drin und Sichtrechner,
die ich mir dazwischendrin angelegt hab. Usage. Moment. Mal gucken, ob ich die in einen Screenshot
übertragen kann. Ja. 100 Euro. Nee, ich hab noch kein Flex Tape. Aber da waren die
ganzen Test Server und so dabei. Normalerweise kostet's nur 35 Euro oder so, die ganzen Kisten
zusammen. Wechsel zu Digital Ocean. Nee, warum? Da ist noch teurer. Bei Digital Ocean hätte
ich dafür 400 Euro oder so bezahlt. Kegweight. Muss grad mal den ganzen Crap wieder löschen.
Muss grad mal die ganzen Server wieder löschen, die ich nicht benutze, bevor ich's vergesse.
Genau, hier. Very nice. So, sehr schön. Genau, ich wechsle lieber Genta Cloud.
Ja, passt doch eigentlich. War ja noch relativ Templates. Hatte ich doch in dem Ort noch,
wo ich ausgeführt hab. Aber danach, dann kaltet nicht den Servernamen, den er sucht. Aha.
Die rufen an. Okay, die sind hartnäckig. Ey, okay, das ist voll, das ist komplett hängen
geblieben. Aber ich hab den Server eh gelöscht jetzt. Alles klar, heute haben wir richtig
Spaß gelernt. Exzellent, ich muss mal rebooten, dass ich ein ordentliches neues Hintergrundbild
bekomme. Das ist nämlich das allerwichtigste heute, dass ich noch ein ordentliches Hintergrundbild
bekomme. Über Bing Image of the Day, der einzige Service, für den ich Bing verwende, für mein
Hintergrundbild. Es hat einer gefragt, was das für ein Niedlungserstes ist. Manjaro
mit E3 WM. Und FPS-Counters, allerwichtigste, was man in einer VM braucht. Okay, besseres
Hintergrundbild als das letzte. Exzellent. So, nochmal kurz Updates machen. Jawoll. Leute,
ich hab den Postman installiert, ich hab nicht Postwoman installiert, die es ja auch gibt,
weil Postman ist das Patriarchat in Paket-Variante. Das darf nicht sein, dass es nur Postman gibt.
Also jetzt kein Witz, es gibt ernsthaft, es gibt ein Paket, was Postwoman heißt, weil
man Konkurrenz zu Postman schaffen wollte. Aber jeder wie er will. Ey, wenn es das bessere
Programm ist, dann hat es sogar was gebracht. Wobei man ja ganz korrekterweise, da sieht
man, was es für witzige Ausmaße mittlerweile annimmt. Man darf ja eigentlich gar nicht
Postwoman sagen, sondern muss Post... Fuck, ich hab vergessen, wie muss man sagen? Postwoman
muss man sagen. Woman. Weil woman geht ja nicht. Es darf ja nicht sein, dass man woman mit
man drin ausspricht. Das ist Womxn, genau Womxn war es. Das ist geil. Die Welt hat heute
echt schon ein bisschen Dachschaden. Womxn, Alter. Ich kenn ernsthaft, ich will nicht
ausschließen, dass es welche gibt, aber ich kenn niemand weibliches, der Womxn genannt
werden will. Wobei, Moment. Ich bin Informatiker, Kellerkind, ich kenn eh keine Frauen. Also
ist das nicht repräsentativ. Nee, aber ich kenn ernsthaft niemand, der Womxn genannt
werden will. Can't wait. Ja gut, Latinx, die machen sich ja selbst drüber lustig. Das
ist ja eh geil. Die Amis, die Amis sind der Meinung, quasi Latino, Latina geht nicht
und sagen Latinx und die Latinos und Latinas selber sagen fuck off und wollen das überhaupt
nicht. Die Welt ist mittlerweile teilweise echt schon verrückt, was das angeht. Ist
der Wahnsinn. Ich verfolge das teilweise recht amüsiert. Manchmal schlagen sie ein bisschen
über die Strenge allesamt. Wobei die Gegenseite auch geil ist. Die übertreibt es dann erst
recht. Und dazwischen irgendwo, irgendwo dazwischen gibt's da noch 4gen, die dafür
sorgen, dass Okayhand und Pepe auf einmal rassistisch sind und Hate Speech. Wobei ich
mir sicher bin, die wünschen sich heute wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil, dass dieser Trollversuch
nicht so gut geklappt hätte. Da muss ich mal überlegen, ja. Fortran hat so lange rumgetrollt,
bis es irgendwann Mainstreammedien aufgegriffen haben, dass Pepe und Okayhand White Power
ist und Pepe ist auch irgendwas Rassistisches. Also sprich, die haben so lange rumgetrollt,
bis das Mainstreammedien aufgegriffen haben, haben darüber berichtet und mittlerweile ist
es so schlimm, dass echte Nazi-Gruppierungen bei den Amis Okayhand als Erkennungssymbol
verwenden. Also das ist quasi vom Troll zur Realität geworden, weil die Leute so dumm
sind, Alter. Das tut weh teilweise einfach nur. Die sind so hängen geblieben alle. Und
ich glaube, dass da sogar ausnahmsweise sich sogar mal Fortran wünscht, es hätte nicht
so gut funktioniert, ihr Trollversuch. Oh Mann, da war es echt... Ich bin der Meinung,
wir sollten alle mal dem Dalai Lama auf Twitter folgen. Ich hab's überhaupt nicht mit irgendwelchen
religiösen Sachen, aber der erzählt viel sinnvolle Sachen. Unabhängig davon, ob man
jetzt irgendwie da Buddhismussachen da anhängt oder nicht, aber die Aussagen, die der von
sich gibt, der ist halt erleuchtet, der weiß Bescheid. Die sind wirklich Big Brain zum
größten Teil. Da könnten sich alle mal eine Scheibe von abschneiden. Da wäre die Welt
besser. Auf jeden Fall. Da würde jeder auf den anderen ein bisschen Rücksicht nehmen.
Da wäre der Sache schon geholfen, ja. Mr. Lordchris, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön für
den Sub. Ich glaube, ich mach jetzt noch eine Runde Java Hate Speech. Streamst du jetzt
täglich? Ich hab relativ oft gestreamt, letzten Monat, fast täglich, alle 1-2 Tage, aber
diesen Monat ist es ein bisschen weniger geworden wieder, weil ich ein paar andere Projekte
bei mir hab, unter anderem hier den Serverraum Umbau, aber ich guck mal. Common Sense, das
hab ich nicht mitgekriegt, kann ich mir aber gut vorstellen. Ja, manchmal gehen so Versuche
nach hinten los. Ja, was macht eigentlich der Frazier? Ist der Frazier noch am Start?
Der ist vorher off gegangen und hat gesagt, ich komm heute nicht mehr on, aber wir kennen
ihn alle. Wenn der das sagt, muss das nicht unbedingt so sein. Nee, der Frazier ist nicht
mehr on. Der Helter-Steine ist on. Auch Frankfurter, den hab ich mal gesehen, den hab ich mal gesehen
am Richtung Südbahnhof. Ich hab aber nichts gesagt. Wollte jetzt nicht hier irgendwie...
Lass mal Youtube-Video zusammen machen, null. Aber ich dachte mir nur, als ich vorbei war,
den kennste doch, den hast du doch irgendwo mal gesehen schon. Wieso Java Hate? Immer.
Es gibt zwei Sachen, die ich gerne flame, Java und C++. Und Java eigentlich nur aus
Spaß an der Freude, Java ist gar nicht so schlecht, aber C++ flame ich gerne und C++ ist auch
noch schlecht und hat jeden Flame verdient. Alter die Musik, was jetzt? Hilfe. Lass
mal Klemmbausteine spielen. Ach stimmt, Lego darf man ja nicht mehr, sonst ist Lego Abmahnung
gleich raus. Allein schon die Aussprache geht nicht. Du meinst C++? C++ ist mittlerweile
so abgedreht, dass noch nicht mal die Leute in diesem Standard-Cremium sitzen, noch was
Einheitliches produziert bekommen. Die könnten sich tatsächlich von C-Sharp, was das angeht,
echt mal eine Riesenscheibe abschneiden. Das sind auch genug Dinge, wo ich mich frage,
was macht Microsoft da? Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist das ziemlich konsistent gelöst
und es kommen auch sinnvolle Neuerungen rein, die dann auch sich gut integrieren. Nicht einfach
irgendwie, alte Pointer-Klasse ist scheiße, wir machen jetzt einfach zwei neue oder unsere
default String-Klasse sackt, nehm doch irgendwie was anderes. Wir machen eine komplett wirre
Lambda-Syntax oder was auch immer. So ist halt C++. Man kann in C++ schon viel machen,
das ist halt einfach wirr unanstrengend. Java ist nicht schlecht, ja ich flame Java eigentlich
bloß weil ich es witzig finde, nicht weil ich es schlecht finde. Java ist nicht schlecht,
das einzig schlechte an Java ist Oracle. Also Microsoft hat mit.NET echt 180 Grad Kernwände
gemacht mit ihrem Open Source Movement und GitHub Zeug da. Also es kommt auch nicht von
ungefähr, dass.NET mittlerweile beliebter ist wie jemals zuvor, was dann echt cool ist,
weil ich mag.NET und C Sharp. Java flame wegen den Chinesen, ja die Chinesen verwenden
gerne Java. Ja gut, Header Files ist eh so ein Ding, das ist auch so was. Warum C++?
Es ist das Jahr 2021, warum gibt es sowas wie Header Files überhaupt noch? Was soll
das Scheiß denn? Guckt euch irgendeine x-beliebige Sprache an, die die letzten 30 Jahre rausgekommen
ist und guckt es euch ab. Header Files ist eines der unsinnigsten Dinger, das das heute
immer noch gibt. Denkt euch ein ordentliches Modulformat aus, hat auch den Vorteil, dass
Entwicklertools einfacher zu basteln sind. Ich meine die Autocompletion für C++ ist
ja sogar in Visual Studio kacke, ist in Sea Lion kacke und also sprich, das sind die größten
Dinger. Der Cute Creator ist auch nicht so toll, was das angeht, weil verblickt keiner
mal durch. Dann führt man sowas wie Auto ein, was ja eigentlich eine ganz coole Idee ist.
Es kann ja theoretisch kein Auto in C++ sogar noch ein bisschen mehr als war in C sharp,
ist aber von der Idee her das ähnliche, quasi ein Schlüsselwort, um den Typ abzuleiten
und dann verkackt man das, dass man sich nicht mehr anzeigen lassen kann, was für ein Typ
eigentlich unten drunter ist. Das ist so alt, das nennt sich schon Tradition. Ja die haben
es ja versucht in irgendeinem der letzten C++ Standard irgendwelche Module einzuführen,
aber ich habe es irgendwie nicht geschafft. Weiß ich nicht, wie es da aktuell aussieht.
Hast du auf deinem Staubsauger, was hast du auf deinem Staubsauger Roboter jetzt noch
was extra drauf laufen als fahrendes Nass oder so? Ne das Ding kann nichts, ich wollte
ja da mal Minecraft drauf laufen lassen auf dem Staubsauger, ich sag euch Leute, Minecraft
auf dem Staubsauger, das wäre übelst viral gegangen auf YouTube. Leider läuft das nicht.
Es ist ein Ubuntu glaube 14.04 drauf, ne, irgendeine arme Architektur, du kriegst nichts
gescheit nachinstalliert und ich mein 512 MB RAM würden eigentlich reichen. Ja also
es ging nicht, also was ich aktuell auf einem Staubsauger Roboter drauf laufen hab, ist
das Webinterface, ja Webinterface von Staubsauger Roboter, Karte vom Wohnzimmer, sonst ist da
nichts drauf, ne. Tja, heutzutage würden die wahrscheinlich einfach alles einkassieren,
würde heute überall was drauf sein. By the way, ich weiß wie das ist bei der Hausdurchsuchung
dabei zu sein, ich hatte selbst noch keine, aber mein Vater hatte schon eine, schon zwei,
weil er, hab ich euch ja mal erzählt, komische Dinger getrieben hat. Also das was ihr heute
auf YouTube in Scam Videos seht, das hat mein Vater alles Real Life gemacht und besser als
die Scammer. Den haben sie nicht erwischt, also die haben ihn erwischt, aber sie haben
ihn nicht dafür verurteilt bekommen, weil die Leute freiwillig unterschrieben haben.
Der hat, ich weiß nicht ob ich euch schon mal erzählt habe, aber der hatte eine Partnervermittlung
in Frankfurt und hat halt keine Partner vermittelt. Ne, ne, ne, ne, nicht die Story. Der hatte
eine Partnervermittlungsagentur aufgemacht und hat halt Fake Partner vermittelt. Das
lief dann so, da kam irgendeine Oma, ich sag jetzt einfach mal eine Oma, irgendeine ältere
Frau kam dann hier hin und hat gemeint, oh mein Mann ist gestorben und sie sucht ja irgendwie
immer noch nach jemandem und da hat er dir einen Vertrag aufgeschwätzt und hat ihr dann
auch Männer geschickt, die angeblich von dieser Agentur sind und auch Frauen suchen und das
waren halt alles gepriefte Leute zum schöne Augen machen, die quasi dann zu 20 Omas heimgefahren
sind und dort quasi ein bisschen verliebt vorgespielt haben, sodass die Omas halt schön
ihre Vermittlungsbeiträge bezahlen. Der hatte da so 5 Typen oder so? Der hat die richtig
gescannt, Alter, der hat die richtig hardcore gescannt und das witzige ist, dass, die haben
ihn ja auch danach dann angezeigt und der war ja sogar irgendwie über ein halbes Jahr in
Untersuchungshaft oder so, da ging es, damals ging es echt, wo ich klein war, ich hab das
nur so am Rande mitbekommen, also sprich, da ging es richtig rund und die haben ihn,
die haben ihn nichts dafür verurteilen können, weil die Verträge so gut geschrieben waren,
dass das eigentlich dort drinnen stand, dass es ein Scam war, aber die Leute haben es trotzdem
unterschrieben, ne, ne, da ist nichts verjährt, wie gesagt, die haben ihn ja versucht deswegen
zu erwischen und das ist aber wie gesagt auch 30 Jahre her mittlerweile oder so, da war ich
wirklich klein, wo es da richtig zur Sache ging oder 25 Jahre her, da war ich wirklich
noch klein und es muss wohl so gewesen sein, dass dann ein paar von den Omas vor Gericht
ausgesagt haben und der Richter muss die wohl wirklich wortwörtlich gefragt haben, warum
haben sie das unterschrieben, wie kann man sowas unterschreiben, also mein Vater hat
viel Scheiße gebaut, ich hab mit dem nicht so allzu guten Kontakt, aber das nehme ich
ihm nicht wirklich übel, da gehören zwei Seiten dabei, Scammer und Leute, die sich
scammen lassen, so wie auf YouTube, ich finde es jetzt nicht geil, Omas zu verarschen, aber
das hat mich jetzt persönlich nicht so getroffen, der hat andere Dinge getrieben, warum ich mit
ihm nicht mehr allzu viel zu tun haben will, ja, aber deswegen nicht, also, der hat schon
komische Dinge, das stand damals auch irgendwo in der Bildzeitung, da haben sie sich dann
drüber hergemacht, ich kann euch aber eins sagen, das ist echt ein merkwürdiges Gefühl,
wenn ihr klein seid und euer Vater sitzt im Knast, bzw. in Untersuchungshaft war er nicht
wirklich im Knast, sie haben ja auch freigesprochen danach, aber echt komisches Gefühl, da kann
ich mich noch dran erinnern, meine Mutter wollte mir das erst gar nicht erzählen, meine
Mutter wollte mir das damals erst gar nicht erzählen, die hat immer gesagt, der ist im
Urlaub, der ist im Urlaub, wo ist denn der Papa denn, ja der ist im Urlaub, und irgendwann
hat sie dann rausgerückt mit der Sprache, ja, ok, da sitzt er in Untersuchungshaft, der
hat sie gescampt, ne, aber der hat noch andere Dinge getrieben, warum ich nichts damit eben
zu tun haben will, aber das nicht, keine Ahnung, aber nimm doch SSHFS, da brauchst du es nicht
mit Wurschel Studio zu machen, SSHFS kannst du das lokal mounten, ja, bisschen wie die
Raubkopier-Werbung, ja, ja und wie ich da ursprünglich drauf gekommen bin, deswegen
gab es bei uns schon mal ne Hausdurchsuchung, meine Mutter hat sich ja damals schon von ihm
getrennt und die waren dann bei uns in der Wohnung, haben da durchsucht, ob da nicht noch
irgendwelche Beweise zu finden sind gegen meinen Vater, und später hat er dann auf
Ebay mal irgendwelche Scam-Dinger versucht und da haben sie nochmal durchsucht, also
eins muss man sagen, also mein Vater hat sich nicht gerade mit Ruhm bekleckert was das angeht,
jetzt ist er bestimmt im Scalper-Business, ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung was der
gerade macht, ich wills auch gar nicht wissen, gibt es eine Alternative zu C++, wenn man
ESP2 und 3 programmieren will, ne nicht wirklich, es gibt zwar Micro-Python und es gibt auch
irgendwie ne Rust-Tool-Chain, aber das ist alles Mist, also wirklich gut.
Hatte er ein Gewerbe-Meter-Dating-Sache angemeldet?
Bestimmt, der hatte sogar ein relativ großes Büro in Frankfurt, in dem relativ hohen,
weiß ich noch, das fand ich damals übelst geil dort aus dem Hochhaus zu gucken, klar
hat er das, der hatte ja auch Mitarbeiter, der Firma war ja gar nicht so klein, da hatte
ja auch irgendwie 20 Leute oder so, mein Vater ist jetzt 72 oder so, der scammed heute nicht
mal so viele Leute, wobei der probiert's wahrscheinlich noch, aber es klappt mit 72 nimmer so, ne aber
in der Richtung hab ich echt gar nix von meinem Vater, also geerbt mein ich jetzt ja,
also so an Charakterzügen in der Richtung, gar nix, daher kommt deine Liebe für C++,
hat ja was mit Wirecard zu tun, nein Quatsch, er ist doch alles schon viel älter gewesen,
im Prinzip war das auch nichts großes Internationales, das war halt hier was in Frankfurt, das war
ja noch Pre-Internet, letztendlich machen das aber, zwar ohne Scheiß, ich könnte wetten,
viele Datingseiten machen das heute nicht anders, da wird auch gescampt was das Zeug
hält, sodass es nicht gemerkt wird, da war, ne Cobol war da nicht neu, ich weiß gar nicht,
das muss irgendwie 1990 oder so gewesen sein, 1995 spätestens, heute läuft's genauso ja,
damit genauso auf ähnliche Art und Weise gescampt, deswegen, es ist ja so, die Scams,
die heute im Internet durchgezogen werden, das sind eigentlich Oldschool Scams, die gibt's
teilweise schon lange, auch diese möchtigen Guru Berater und so, was es da alles gibt,
gibt's schon ewig, da ist nicht so viel Neues dabei, das Medium hat sich halt geändert,
heute ist es komm in die Gruppe, früher war es halt irgendwas anderes, aber im Prinzip
ist es der gleiche Scheiß, und die Leute sind damals drauf reingefallen, fallen heute drauf
rein, tja, Leute, ich glaub ich geh jetzt off,
ich geh jetzt off, und vielleicht bin ich morgen direkt wieder am Start, wenn ich erstmal
ein bisschen Streeming Streak habe, da muss der Aufrecht erhalten werden, okay Leute, wir
sehen uns, macht's gut, bis dann, see you.